um
okay good morning everybody good morning
welcome to the uh plans committee
meeting of the 28th of july
welcome to everybody in the room offices
and members of the public and those who
may be watching on tourism youtube
saying
first item on the agenda is well not on
the agenda it's for me to ask all the
committee to introduce themselves and
the opposite present this morning and
i'll start with myself i'm chris leather
and i represent norway
hi i'm ron craney and i represent
infants
good morning my name is peter christie
and i represent a bit more
good morning
simon newton i represent winkley and i'm
substituting this morning for councillor
rosary log
good morning my name is stephen from
golf and i represented the north
good morning my name is pete watson and
i represent broady morning richard
wiseman i represent the sharia language
good morning
[Music]
thank you and then on my left good
morning i'm helen smith and i'm the
planning manager at torridge council
good morning i'm stacy dorian i'm the
head of legal governance
good morning i'm tom vanster i'm the
democratic services manager good morning
i'm sandra democratic services officer
i'm laura davis and principal planning
officer here at orange
thank you thanks everybody
okay if we move on to
the agenda then apologies for absent
thank you yeah two apologies councillor
lock councillor newton substituting
councillor fountain um councillor
harding
substituting but he's not right
thank you
item two on the agenda on pages five to
eleven minutes for the meeting held
on the ninth of june and i'll move those
from the chair second
thank you council officer
[Music]
cancer
[Music]
thank you
that's seven four and one abstention
chair thank you sandler
item three on the agenda is declarations
of interest
i think all members know that off my
heart i'll read it out for the benefit
of members of the public
members was interested to declare should
refer to the agenda item and describe
the nature of their interests when the
item was being considered
elected members of devon county council
and town and parish councils who
considered a planning application by
virtue
of their membership of that council
called a personal interest and are
deemed to have considered the
application separately
on the express views of that council do
not find the members concerned
to consider the application afresh
and i always have it in here that very
often there's extra information on
applications that come from the plans
committee
item four is to agree the agenda between
part one and two we have no thought too
on this
in this people
i can find the urgent matters
i know urgently
[Music]
six is public participation
this is where i advise the committee of
any prior request to speak
made by members of the public and to
advise on the details
the councils public participation
speedwell
we've got 19 contributions
this morning to the five applications
including three board members who want
to speak
and five letters
which the planning manager will read out
um
i'll quickly go through the list and
then so so for the
uh application
there is a student speaking against from
the parish council
the council of dark with the board
member will speak to that one
the languages the green acres in bet
lane keith goodridge a member of the
public speaking event
george smart a member of the public
speaking against
darren drake in support he was a member
of the public
lewis johnson from the architects in
support
on the healthy age as the agent
and also councillor haines as award
members to speak
the staten road
application
there is david and sharon and elton i
want to speak against that's the letter
that we read by our planning manager
also for stanley road is terrentrey
trainer in support he's the agent for
that application
and chancellor haynes again wants to
speak to that award
the brecken park and one david
butterworth speaking the member of the
public against
angie omar speaking against the member
of the public
anthony vickery speaking in support he
was the agent
and again councillor dart
got her name down to speakers board
member
and finally the sunny-side application
we've got stephen trollbridge member of
the public with a letter which we read
out by heaven and also trudy mackie
brown a letter which should be read out
by the planning manager against
we've got um the applicant sandra cause
who's gonna speak in support i'm sorry
that is a letter to be
ready um and also counselor gov the war
member
who is
sent a letter in support which will be
ready well
that's that's all we've got
public speaking and speaking of plans
committees expected at all who return
the plans commitment
that they'll give a fair and
uninterrupted hearing for the planning
officer giving their report and to all
those listed to speak
and the planning committee members when
they begin their consideration
natural is only common courtesy thank
you
right we move on to item seven then
planning applications
the information recommendations and
advice contained in the reports
are correct uh as at the date of
preparation
which is more than 10 days in advance of
the committee meeting
due to these time constraints
any changes or necessary updates to the
reports
will be provided in writing or orally at
the committee meeting
so we move on now to our first
application
which is application 7a
on pages 19-20 of your agenda
thank you chair
so the application is for land opposite
langdon road industrial estates and this
application is being brought back to
plans committee following its initial
consideration in march of this year and
the application is for the development
of the site
provide 38 dwellings with associated
works access and car parking
uh members deferred the application from
the march committee
to seek an updated review of the
viability information
and an additional involvement of board
members in section 106
in particular in relation to the
off-site biodiversity contributions
and in addition further clarification
was also requested by members in
relation to the nhs contribution
so there's an addendum to previous
sponsors reports set out on page 13 of
your agenda and the remainder of the
report is
submitted to you in march
so just to run through
the updates taking place
in terms of viability
members previously queried the validity
and of the review of liability
information which was undertaken by the
district valuer
given the time that it elapsed between
the review and being brought to plans
committee the district valuer has now
undertaken a further review
and this included consideration of the
biodiversity net gain off-site
contribution
and added that one of the costs into the
assessment the conclusions as you'll see
in the report which is an appendix to my
office's report concluded that an
increased on-site affordable housing
provision can be made
in addition to the other contributions
which were requested for the nhs for
transport for secondary school google's
additional infrastructure provision of
bradford environmental school
and on-site the public open space the
biodiversity net gain and a small
contribution towards off-site affordable
housing
so those will set out in the addendum
section of the report so the conclusion
is that the policy compliant provision
of the site affordable housing of 11
units can now be provided
which eight would be the social rent and
three is intermediate
just as a side note members will note
the date of the updated review is the
fourth of april and again it has a
three-month validity written into it as
the district valued as a standard we
have gone back to the district value to
confirm again whether this is still
valid in advance of this committee and
they've confirmed that they are happy to
agree an extension of its validity from
three to five months so it remains valid
for numbers to consider today
the second bullet points
um a meeting has been held between board
members
the chair of parish council
officers and the agent for the applicant
in relation to the off-site biodiversity
net gain contribution and where it would
be
an alternative site to be found within
the parish for the provision of the
relevant habitats sufficient to offset
those lost in the site was discussed
and the implications of making sure
we've got the correct habitat type as
well as
the
requirement for long-term maintenance
and management of that area
and was discussed in quite some detail
and it was agreed that these are quite
onerous and that the parish council
wouldn't necessarily be in a position to
undertake peace
and it was agreed that the northern
biosphere provides the best option at
the moment for this
contribution to be
directed towards
and now set out previously to members
biosphere but identified projects
which would provide the right type of
habitat elsewhere within the district
and manage that on an ongoing basis for
us
and ward numbers have also been updated
on all the amended heads of terms of the
section 106 by our email in advance of
the meeting
the nhs contribution
and further clarification has been
sought from the nhs and i think there
was a question as to whether the money
was to be used for a review of the gp
provision or whether it's actually to be
used for
physical infrastructure and then
confirmed the fact that it is intended
to create a new gp's consulting room to
hope and increased um demand within the
broadway surgery and that's where the
contribution will be directed
and i will run back with the same size
as i gave you in march and just to
to go back through the development so
we've got the application sites
into the northeastern side of bradworthy
and the supplement boundary goes around
the application site so it's within the
settlement
and the highway runs
around to the north of the site you've
got an industrial estate london road
which is june west and lower meadow
dwellings to the south
and you've got birth dwellings to the
north
eastern corner of the site and
agricultural buildings to the west
and the supplement boundary includes the
application site as well as the parcel
ground immediately to the north
and there was a previous planning
commission on the site for 28 dwellings
and this has now lapsed
and we've got the aerial photograph
this shows the application site we've
got a hedge language device the
application site from the parcel of land
to the north and also shows the
dwellings to the south
and to the northeast as well as the
agricultural buildings to the east
and the industrial units to the west
now we'll run through photographs of the
sites
from the entrance to the industrial site
around the road
looking
north west across the site
this view of the nearest property to the
south western corner which is a lower
meadow
new across from the industrial state
existing access just by the village
science and just behind the lap post
there and that would be closed up a new
access formed
this is a view across the site from
the west
looking over
towards lumar in the distance
you can just see the rooftops of the
properties that live on there
line
and then panning around to the
western side of the site
a view along the
existing highway from the existing
access which runs around the wall of the
site
and then views from the existing site
entrance down towards the south and then
panning around
to
existing properties at lower meadow
a view back in towards the village
and the existing access point which is
just by the village sign you can see
that
um the highway
wraps around the north of the site
and then moves across the north of the
site so the land that's in the
immediately behind the train isn't
actually part of the application site
that's from the northern parcel and the
activation cycle behind the further
hedge line
same shade on that
yes that northern immediate parcel of
land would have been developed as part
of the application
and then a view down towards the
properties of
which goes to the northeast
and then views from from those
properties back across the application
side and you can just pick out the
agricultural buildings in the east
i'll show you inside the picture then
we're going to be back across towards
lower meadows
so we've got a proposed site plan
we've got 38 dwellings we've got a mix
of detached seven detached from terrace
properties
we've got two one bedroom flats and then
the remainder are a mix of two three and
four bed dwellings
we've got two areas of play space
and one chain to the north
and one and a larger one to the southern
part of the site and the new access
would be proposed in eastern boundary
you can see there with a separate
pedestrian access also being provided uh
there'll be a new junction onto the
highway with 17 visibility slaying
direction
and the development seeks to retain
applications and trees around the
boundaries of the site
and but would result in removal of some
of the existing hedgerows from within
the sites
and it was attenuation upon the surface
water drainage it was indicated to the
northeast of the site and also a bowel
water power pumping station
indicates that the pink colour
and i've got additional landscaping
that's proposed around the attenuation
point
proposed drainage plans that shows the
attenuation part a little bit more
clearly and it's been indicated and
provided for a one in 100 clear events
and plus allowance for climate change
and the surface water will then be
discharged at an attenuated break you
can see adjacent watercourse
move on to the access arrangements
that's details in the proposed new
access which closes the request paper
and we'll move around into the sites and
the pedestrian access as well
and then we've got a number of and plans
of the various house types which we can
run through fairly swiftly if members
are happy with that and there are a
number of them shows a mix of different
dwelling types
all of the traditional design to be
proposed all jaw-pitched roots
predominantly got rendered to the
elevations with some brick detailing and
great concrete trials onto the roof
lakes and we've got three bungalow units
included within
the propane
all properties worked out to off street
parking spaces through the dwellings
and there would also be parking
provision for the two one bedroom flat
so we've got three parking spaces
between the two units
some street scenes
show some cross sections through the
sites which shows a fairly varied street
scene in terms of a mix of house types
so just to run quickly through the main
planning considerations that set out the
longest report
and as i mentioned previously the
previous plan commissioned
site has now last um but the application
site is located in a business settlement
boundary so it will be supported by
policy sta7 in terms of the station
strategy and
that's the brad worthing which is attack
quality brd
and in terms of affordable housing and i
think uh as as i outlined earlier the
national policy can buy an on-site
provision with a reduced off-site
contribution
and but we've got the 11 on the science
units
um
in terms of housing mix we would have a
mix of one two three and four bedroom
units and and that's proposed to be
broadly in keeping with the
requirements of the uh council's
headphone reports and so it's considered
to record the policy sta 17
plan and we've got a condition to secure
the housing mix um within the office's
recommendation that's division 16
and landscape parity appearance we as i
said before retaining the majority of
the hedgerows and trees around the main
boundaries
the sites and an entry protection plan
has been submitted to confirm into
details
and the application site is on the edge
of the settlement and we've been seen
within most longer distances be used as
part of the surrounding build-up
environment in the adjacent settlement
and we've included a number of
conditions to ensure we've got some more
details coming forward in terms of the
levels of the
buildings and it's condition seven and
the detailed landscaping plan which is
set up in conditions eight and ten
on this basis there your office has been
considered
the development would be including the
pulses st14 and dm08 a concerns with
landscape impacts in terms of design
um the proposed dwellings will be
predominantly two stories in height
another traditional design
um
with the materials palette which has
been keeping with surroundings and we've
also had a building for life
and assessment and specifically to meet
provisions and policy dmo form
in terms of heritage uh the county
council's archaeologist requested the
inclusion of a condition for a written
scheme of investigation that's condition
three overall recommendation
in terms of residential amenities um
within the society within development um
recommendation includes a condition for
obscure glazing there are a number of
dwellings that's condition 20
but in terms of its existing
surroundings we had initial concerns
from the environmental protection
officer about the relationship to the
industrial units at london road
had additional information about noise
mitigation measures and as a result
we've got no objection from the
environmental protection officer i am
subject to a noise impact assessment and
mitigation measures condition that's
condition 19.
in terms of air quality they also raise
munition concerns
about proximity to the agriculture
advance to the
and we've had some further information
submitted about that in terms of the
size of the units and the use of
where the openings are on the buildings
and which are considered mitigating
factors in terms of noise and odour and
the environmental protection officers
finally comment notes
that a harmful impact is unlikely to
resolve these
uh in terms of access and parking and
the high resolution county council has
raised no objections to department and
access arrangements we have a number of
conditions um requiring provision of
details which are reflected in the
report
in terms of drainage uh again current
council's blood risk engineers have
raised no objection further to
submission of additional information and
we have a pre-commencement condition for
a detailed surface water drainage design
condition before
and we've got no objections in relation
to power water drainage by southwest
water
in terms of technology we've got
condition 10 which seeks to secure
atlantic and ecological management plans
for developments
and we also have condition 17 which
ensures that the developments
entertainment according to those
recommendations and ecological reports
and this includes minimizing external
lighting and retaining various existing
habitat features and providing vatican
practices from development
and
we've already discussed the biodiversity
net gain contribution would also be
secured as part of the section 106
agreement
and the section 106 as i outlined with
boring set out in
um
on page 13 in the addendum of your
report will include a number of
different elements
and it will include contributions to a
number of number of features like the
nhs and education
and the securing of affordable housing
on site and also for the public open
states on site so the proposed
development is recommended for approval
subjects to the various conditions
outlined in the offices report and the
heads of terms set out
in the agenda
lovely thank you for that
comprehension review of this application
again
um
right our question speaker this morning
speaking against it's true london from
the parish council
i'm sure you've
thank you good morning thank you chair
thank you everybody um bradley parish
council remain opposed to the
application uh the parish does not need
these 38 houses it never has uh
bravoline has expanded at an alarming
rate and it's losing its identity as a
village
without employment opportunities and the
parish the building and the occupation
of these houses will be totally
unsustainable we have no useful bus
service and an over reliance on private
cars this is not going to add anything
to the torrid carbon neutral pledge
myself and the war councillors have
attended meetings to discuss the
viability of the site and the large
amount by the biodiversity net gain
money that will be spent enhancing
another site miles from our parish we
thank your officers for their time on
them however the fact remains of this
huge sum of 123
490 pounds that needs to be spent on
recreating a habitat that will be
destroyed by developing this
habitat-rich field should sensibly tell
us that the site is not right to be
developed at all
um we would also like to point out again
as laura said that the application of
the 28 houses has now elapsed
we have concerns about the viability of
the site we have studied the latest
viability assessment report and we can
see that the site is only just
financially libel at present
we believe this is why the site has been
sorry has remains unsold for five years
since 2017.
we welcome the 11 affordable houses
since we are well aware of how vital it
is to create new homes for younger
residents
people speak up a little bit
um we have concerns about the viability
of the site we have studied the latest
viability assessment report and we can
see that the site is only just financial
financially viable and present we
believe this is why the site has been
remained unsold for five years since
2017
we welcome the 11 affordable houses as
we are well aware of how vital it is to
create new cheaper homes for younger
residents who want to remain in the area
close to families and friends
however we have strong doubt that this
number of affordable housing will remain
at 11 once the development of the site
begins
can torridge give us assurances that
these 11 houses will not be reduced
because of commercial viability planning
is granted no it cannot this site
remains a site with a huge amount of
financial obligations and we are aware
that it will be affordable housing that
will be renegotiated by the developer
when building costs of material prices
increase
this has happened to on so many sites
already on both tourism parish councils
and palaces to stop this no matter how
much they verbally support the delivery
of affordable housing to stop its
eroding of affordable housing lovers of
their district we all need legal
assurances developers must predict to
deliver the number of housing that is
requested by your authority there there
should be no renegotiation at all by
tourist at a later date
parish council does not want another
play area in the village it's already
responsible for the maintenance and
insurance of one large recreational area
and the proposed play area in this
development and another um
recreational area the parish will have
three
recreational areas we do not need three
we are a village not in town but this is
what the officers want we live in this
part of the section 106 that perhaps
could take on the responsibility of
these extra players as part of the 106
obligation because we will not
thank you for your time
thank you
the next big reward comes with
i'll keep it really brief because soon
said it all in a nutshell and ultimately
we don't think we should be planning
here um it is outside of the village the
the main road is living i've walked in
at night it's not a suitable location to
situate family housing
we appreciate the level of affordable
housing that is wonderful
however will they be built out will it
be viable at the time
we'll leave that in an open book
um we have investigated the biodiversity
money thing within the village it is
simply not feasible for that to happen
so consequently that money will have to
be spent elsewhere
um if as you said that amount of money
is needed to accept the damage done
don't do the damage
[Music]
thank you guys
that's the uh
that's for the speakers for this
application i noticed council hard in
his jointed
chair got stuck without building lorry
in the village you know he's just gonna
get out he won't be able to take part in
the vote and deliberation on this
application because he didn't he won't
give them the staff
but after that we'll be able to take it
um right okay well members will
remember that we did have this march and
there were several questions raised that
i think have been answered in the
presentation
to do the 106 mainly and especially i
think one of them was the
the money that was requested by the
health authority which didn't specify
anything in particular i will say i am
surprised when you read on the bottom of
page 27
that the brother of a neighborhood plan
when they were doing their
consultation um
prior to one of the priorities was more
healthcare so
now we know it's going to go towards
another consulting room but when you
look at
on page 13
the money that's being spent on
education 147 million 148 thousand
123 and a half thousand
on off concept biodiversity
a meager 13 000 pound towards and you
can an additional consumer
i know it's worked out to a formula
um
it's a
drop in the ocean building a new
consulting room on that practice one
would think that
everything that all this money that's
coming through with all those things
the whole cost of that comes to people
for the natural priority could be paid
for but as i said it is worth too
um
before i ask any members to contribute
there
can you give the assurance about the
affordable health things
yeah
so
the recommendation before members is
that permission is only granted if
there's a legal agreement that's signed
and on the basis of the heads of terms
that's set out in your report
and
so one can assume that that is the basis
for any decision
it is um
in the council's gift to not accept any
negative renegotiation on a legal
agreement within five years of the date
of that legal agreement that is what
planning legislation indicates um
there's no right of appeal on that we do
on um where there's a reasonable basis
for renegotiation
do enter into discussions with
developers within a five-year period um
there's not a risk to us in terms of an
appeal we don't however some councils
have been subject to judicial review and
found unreasonable on certain occasions
so um
it is in our power to decide whether or
not we would want to enter into any
renegotiation if it's a significant
difference if it goes from policy
compliance to
zero coming forward it does you know
raise the question that final balance
would change and the weight that would
be putting the decision to affordable
housing there's no affordable housing
that planning balance has changed so you
know i can we can give comfort office
the level that we would look at any any
such approach
um
you know proportionately
and and appropriately and it is to
decide whether within five years we
would want to
negotiate
and would that come back to this
[Music]
um we would consult with board members
as
the approach we take
um that said if it was a significant
difference and we felt that actually it
couldn't be done us to do the variation
because it was ordering our new proposal
then
it's likely an application would need to
come back in and it would be the board
members um you know position to call
back to community again i don't think
would be engaging with board members
thank you for that i would like to start
from this
councillor christian
there's just a couple of questions
really um on page 13
[Music]
the last of the section 106 the 1
315 pound walls offside affordable
housing division
which seems
peanuts but on page um
20 or it's actually on page 21 right at
the top
the commuted sum according to our own
octopus is 56 000.
how come there's a difference that's the
first question give me another one
um the
policy compliance situation would be as
set out by our strategic enabling
officers that's what's on page 21
in their consultation response i think
that was 56
000 pounds which offsets the additional
point whenever it was of a unit um for
the providing site and as part of the
district valuers assessment they got to
a point where they can provide
viably all of the required on-site
provision
but it would result in a reduction in
the off-site contribution
to ensure that we can provide all the
other section 106 contributions and now
our policy obviously emphasizes that we
would rather have on-site provision of
affordable housing rather than off-site
and so officers feel that this is a
reasonable balance to have reached
and the what set out page 21 is is part
of my original report so it hasn't been
amended
if you like in light of
the deferred application what's on page
13 reflects sort of the updated bird
situation
thank you the second point was
the viability study
um i looked at page 76 which is
like you know the vibe
[Music]
and this is something i really can't get
my head around but
the acquisition costs of the land
they're quoted at uh two hundred and
four uh
hundred thousand pounds per acre
and yet that's a benchmark figure it's a
kind of average figure across the area
um and yet the first application was in
2015 when i assumed
the land price was a lot lower
and as the land price goes up so we lose
out on our section 106. and yet i don't
know what price was paid for this land
it's never in our viability study what
was the price of originally paid because
any builder who buys land then 10 years
later applies he's already made a huge
profit
that we lose um i can't get my head
around this that
why do we use this benchmarking why
can't we see
the actual price paid for the land
because it does affect the whole
viability
and i'll just come back on that point
answer christie so there's sort of a
national prescribed methodology for
liability assessment and the district
valuer who we
go to externally to review um viability
appraisal they adopt the benchmark land
value approach so it's consistent across
all liability appraisals so at a point
in time they're looking at what the
reasonable land value would be as
opposed to what may have been may have
been paid and that's just the
methodology that's prescribed i
appreciate that it is you know
frustrating not to see that exact
value or quite so but it is the
methodology and his protective approach
means that the way that the db
thing is the land banking right now
i think the point is on that and i have
lot of sympathy with that the view i
think that council of chris is putting
forward is
if you've got to go out and buy a site
to develop that's fair enough you put
down
directly 100 000 an acre for acquisition
but where you've inherited where you
actually own the land
it's still a hundred thousand pounds per
acre because if they've had to go and
buy it
when they haven't
this is something i think we'll be
taking up when we do get that
consultation on section one fix
agreements
at councillor mcgovern yeah very much mr
question about the biodiversity net gain
you've got 123 000 pounds so it's
offside by diversity
undertaken by the north devon biosphere
aberration cliffs
and or rovers by grassland dish and edge
grow habitats
how does that benefit breadwinner at all
it doesn't benefit brad where
is that one [ __ ] um
so the locals unfortunately
will potentially suffer and my opinion
is up from it and then the diversity
which we're keen on
is offset in other villages
the the approach that we're taking is if
it cannot be provided on site is that we
would put it to a third party is to
where the money can be reasonably spent
but the priority is that we need to
provide the correct habitat type
and it needs to be able to be maintained
and monitored on an ongoing long-term
basis to make sure that it is therefore
biodiversity benefits um
the
environment act and
we've only got the primary legislation
at the moment i'm sure a lot more born
out into the course but it does put an
emphasis on the fact that larger scale
sites
and can benefit biodiversity greater
than a lot of tiny pockets if you like
we're adding on to application sites and
and we're very lucky that we have the
northern biosphere here to be able to
have work as that sort of a third party
in terms of taking on management
maintenance and
being able to bring forward projects
we need to be assured that there is a
project there
and that it can provide the right
habitats at the moment the biodiversity
sorry the biosphere are saying that they
have projects in those locations listed
which would be the very specific habitat
types
and so we have the confidence that they
will be delivered it doesn't mean that
other sites might not come forward in
the graduating parish in the future but
right now those are the ones the
biosphere
are focused on and they can confirm that
they are going to be undertaken
on the very diversity issues i noticed
on day 13 the second paragraph from the
bottom that the agent
has confirmed the land from the north of
the application site we saw it on the
[Music]
on the presentation which is within the
applicant's ownership
has been assessed by an ecologist and
would only contribute a very small
amount to the required biodiversity of
setting for the development but when i
looked
at the photographs of the site and i do
know about silicon
it's quite a boggy marshy area and i
think the line to the north
looks as good on the photographs it's
similar but i did put
when i read through it why are you with
a big question mark why that couldn't be
enhanced but perhaps it's already
it's like the circus due to be developed
i think actually
i mean we
the agent did put forward that their
ecologists have reviewed that part of
the site and that yes
some biodiversity gains can be provided
there but ultimately quite a negligible
percentage of what they need to provide
so it was felt that it made more sense
to put the entire contribution together
rather than to have two separate
elements if you like right just getting
back to the
um point that councilman got made that
none of this offsetting benefits in the
broadway area where that little
involved could have been enhanced even
if people need a small degree and the
rest of the money could then have gone
off-site elsewhere
i think that would have been a better
use of the biodiversity
money
right anybody else want to contribute or
the other thing that was mentioned by
the parish representative was the play
areas
there's two of their
israel management by the council where i
saw there was a management scheme
in other words a parish council walked
left
but they won't be left out into the
country
that's true the sexual assaults
would obviously seek this to secure the
provision on site of those and then for
the maintenance and management of them
often as you know with other sites these
involve setting up a management company
for the residents of that particular
site and it's measured on an ongoing
basis right see if the parish council
want to get involved in that in due
course then kind of a legal discussion
will take place outside of
this particular application
right well
council christian i'll just ask one
simple question uh when the officer was
presenting it she said the the area was
actually within the village development
area did you call it
yeah i look at the map on page 12
of our agenda
he was in the village to me
[Music]
yes
it's because of the historic planning
commission on the site
that at the time that the match was on
the the big plus for me is is is the 11
affordable dwellings on the side and
as helen's already explained to us the
position of that within the model states
but um
we don't often get that higher
percentage of the affordable care sites
i'm very pleased about that i'm going to
move from the chair that we do approve
this i'll second them to against the
watson second name
could
[Music]
or
chancellor leather or
pencil in the golf okay
newton against
cancer watson or
cancer wiseman
[Music]
that's six four chair and two against
thank you
[Music]
application 7d now
which is on pages 91 to 113 of your
agenda
uh hello yes
okay so um the application reference is
up on the screen for you the application
proposes
um the correction two dwelling the
application was made in full
and land adjacent to green acres pit
lane apple door the application has been
called to committee by board member
councillor haines for the following
reasons
um piecemeal development which should
name police development under
one zero
seven six nine government policy north
seven
state the allocated fight should be
developed in a comprehensive manner
this development would create another
access onto pit hill and potentially
serving further development on the lands
marked in blue therefore adversely
affecting traffic and pedestrian safety
from the narrow lane
lack of green infrastructure contrary to
normal zero seven requirements
no affordable housing and drainage
issues adversely affecting amenities of
neighboring property
there are some verbal updates for
members and there is an amended site
location plan the reference of this plan
is up on the screen this is the plan
that was shown and shared with you at
the site of it it does simply have an
amendment to the blue line which
identifies other lands within the
applicant's ownership and as you'll
recall blue line have slightly been
amended to take in the access and it's
joining up
to pick here itself
and should members be minded to approve
the application then um it would need to
be minuted that that's the plan
reference that should be should be on
any um
any minute
that there have been um some post agenda
publication representations i'm aware
that i think all of these have been
circulated directly to committee members
so i don't propose to read them all out
and the key issues raised and there are
highways matters that have been raised
um these these matters don't necessarily
raise anything new that isn't already
set out within your agenda report
um
also concerns have been raised over
legal ownership of the site and
[Music]
this would only be an issue if the
council hasn't carried out the correct
process and ensured that the correct
certificate has been signed on the
application um and in discussions with
the agent it has been confirmed that
the the land ownership is is consistent
with the certificate that's been signed
so we do not consider those concerns to
have any implications for your
consideration of the planning
application today and
finally some concerns were raised over
uncertainty over the heights of the
dwellings on site and as members will
recall from the site visit last week i
did go into quite a lot of detail on
levels on the site and also the heights
of the dwellings
um against those levels so i think he
can be assured that there's no
uncertainty over what is being proposed
um at certain officer level
and
then finally the third point on there it
is recommended that further that any
permission would benefit from a further
condition should numbers be likely to
approve and that would be a specific
condition to require a detailed method
statement of works for the the um
hedgerow translocation that is proposed
to enable visibility um it would be
prudent to have a detailed method of
works for any such translocation to
ensure firstly it's carried out properly
and secondly and equally importantly
that it's carried out at the appropriate
time
for that verbal updates
just running through the presentation
now this is the site location plan and
as amended you can see the site
extension to the blue line
um the application site is is located um
within the development boundary of apple
door it sits to the south of the built
form of apple door and it has a direct
advantage onto kit hill
um there is a property known as green
acres on the other side of pitt hill
that is the nearest residential property
to the site
and northern is located beyond to the
south
the
the application site itself is
approximately 0.35 hectares
and
depending on
and this
[Music]
side shows the change in levels
apologies the numbers are incredibly
small we did look at this in more detail
on the site with it but the levels do
change across the site the bottom corner
you're looking at
43 minutes of aog
and it does go up as far as 50 to 51
meters at the top part of the
application site rising further beyond
on the blue line to the north
and
as you can see from the location of the
the proposal of map extract the site is
within the development boundary
you know that sits within land that's
identified for development
and allocated as part of quality nor
zero seven
and the area outlined in yellow at the
bottom is currently under construction
for 89 dwellings
the blue section is currently subject to
a live application for 27 dwellings and
it's the red triangle that we're
considering today
now looking at some aerial photos just
to show the site in the wider context of
apple door to the north
um
the apple door football further to the
west which is set on churchill way
wooden road is further about
the closer up um ariel equator you can
see there you can see the relationship
with the property the green acres and
the group of properties to the north
east which is set at the top of the hill
the land to the north is also within the
applicant's own ship
and and does
extend to a higher elevation than the
application site
now just running through some photos
firstly starting the um
the existing access
to the site which is at the top the top
end of pitt hill um it is proposed as
i'll come on to you later where
pedestrian links can be provided so i
just wanted to include this data so you
can see that slight change in level
going up to that existing gateway
let's just show pit hill and the point
of accident when pedestrian link will go
through
now just a series of photos looking down
the site is on the right it's found by a
hedgerow front in pitt hill
which is continuing down again you can
see the site on the right hand side
continuing down that's the entrance to
green acres on the left-hand side you
can just be at the bottom of the road
begin to curve around this is where
the new vehicular access would be
located
and
again this is the area where there will
be vehicular access and a translocation
of this hedge
and you can see in front
just showing the point of access that's
been created into the bakery
the application site apparently behind
and
where this photo was taken the hedgerow
on the right hand side is to be
translocated back as part of
the
current application proposal 27 dwelling
dwelling and a footway provided on the
right hand side subject to parental
sense of course
it's just showing the existing point of
breakthrough into the vacant state
scheme
now looking back up towards the sides
with the hedge on the left now that
would um under the bunny home scheme i
would call it which is the 27 units
would be translocating footway would
reach down
and then moving further up because
roughly in this area that there would be
a single point for access for this
application
further hedge trans location to get um
visibility
and now just continuing back up hill
the green acres on the right
and unless this photo just shows that
the dwelling of green acres has actually
stepped behind some quite extensive
trees um and actually sticks to the
lower level to the site with an
orientation looking south
and this
last couple of photos of the tape was
taking them back up to the top of the
hill and you can see the existing
properties on faith hill are set at a
significantly higher level than the
application site
this is a view from the adjoining part
of the allocation which is subject to an
application the
if approved will
end up with 27 dwellings on it um which
sets that context the the application
site itself will stick lower than the
ridge you can just see up above there
one pete hill would be just on the other
side of the hedge
and this is just nearer to pitt hill
looking back across just to see that
that context is within the allocation
and
presumed
development on that
this is the view from wooder road so
this is the baker estates development
which is well underway now um you can
just see the application sites the light
coming field um beyond so the dwellings
thick the dwelling i'm sorry we'll stick
to within there in the context of the
pit hill properties above
and then the wood of the vagrant stays
scheme further to the south
this is the view from church and wave
this is by the footway joining the
football club um
you can see the properties on pit hill
just at the top here the site
the bunny home scheme is there the
lighter color field field the
application site couldn't be highly
visible from this from this direction
i'm just looking at some photos of a
closer
um point to the site and just panning
around from the existing points of
access
you can see that that change in
topography the existing hedgerow along
the west
which which will found the site within
many homes
and this is the top part of the site
and and on which they propose that way
would go
and then just be on the site now to the
land above which as you can see does
rise rise up away from the site
continuing round showing the properties
on pit hill
and that relationship that they are
about higher elevation we then continue
back down
to the bottom of the site again and you
can see the laker estate scheme without
that
um
panning around
so the proposed booklet would cut
through as indicative was shown in the
top sections there would be a need to
remove a small element of pedro to get
into the bunny homes sites at this point
and again this shows that looking back
where that that's the way we've come
along the top part of the site
it's just looking at the proposed plans
now the site plan on the left shows how
the dwellings were presided within the
application site
and the built form doesn't extend
further than
what it proposed past the bunny home
scheme to the west you can see an
extensive area of tree planting along
the northern section which is the most
prominent section and that
there is drainage proposed
um within the site within each
individual plot to deal with both foul
and surface water drainage that would in
turn
connect the wider infrastructure being
provided for the baker state scheme and
the conditions recommended that
it secures that scheme um
it's it's considered
there is a reasonable prospect of that
drainage instruction would be available
with the connection into in a timely
manner bearing a mining three-year
period then then would have to implement
and this is just sort of an indicative
plan showing how the footwear
could could be cited it is recommended
that the detail has been achieved by a
legal agreement together with its
delivery and ongoing
um availability for public use and
maintenance
management
there is a wider section which will
provide
maintenance access to the field to the
north that would be four meters
and then it reduces down to three meters
with
uh pedestrian gate
something along the lines of this which
could enable
um people with buggies or wheelchair
reasons to be able to access through
um
the very low-key solar-powered lighting
is proposed from a
safety point of view
and the surfacing is composed with some
gravel grid type service service which
will allow performing ability but also
not to be too heavily engineered given
the context for surrounding
like i said it is proposed to secure the
detail of this footwear through a legal
agreement however it would be open to
members to
direct that this
the intent on this plan is sort of
highlighted as being something that
should be followed
this shows the extensive landscaping
associated with the proposal this is
reflective of the sensitive um landscape
location the allocation policy does just
seek to limit
landscape capcom to landscape character
you can see there is extensive tree
plants and proposed and again this would
be secured by a legal agreement to
ensure its delivery and ongoing
maintenance
and there's also a habitat enhancement
element of that as well and benefits
would also be tree planting along the
southeastern
hedge row and within the fight to pick
to pit hill and
again that would form part of that that
legal agreement ongoing maintenance
requirement
at the bottom of the site where the site
access is there is a need to translocate
or to remove a relatively small section
of hedgerow and then to translocate to
roughly 20 metres to enable visibility
the visibility would be at 43 meters
and just quickly run through these are
the
floor plans
um
[Music]
or
one of the plots
and
two dwellings well similar in
architectural science style to use
different um
different materials
so this drone would have um
natural stone based ground floor level
and then black
timber upper floor level
and the heights from sort of ground
floor up to the ridge is less than eight
meters
and just under eight meters they are
two-story dwelling
however as you can see from the top
image there if you go north due to the
topography it would take the appearance
of a single story dwelling so you're
looking at sort of a five meter height
there from the ground level that would
be visible
and
again these are the side elevations
there is a series of sort of flattened
type privacy screening that's proposed
along the external terraces to ensure um
identity is protected
again this is showing the floor plans
for the the other plots which is
to the west
just using a slightly different material
here with a natural timber cladding
and again this is slightly lower because
it's a lower part of the site again well
it's below eight meters roughly seven
meters ninety
and
and you've got a similar architectural
treatment and again
um screening
along the external terraces which would
be required by condition
you can see how the dwellings stick with
the level within the fact that the
hedgerow boundary was dissolved sloped
to an extent that would help protect
them energy on either side
that's just the conceptuals of really
image of how dwellings would look
showing the tree planting a more mature
stage and
that just gives an impression of how the
dwellings would work
and and these just show the sort of
evolution of the scheme it's very much
the design and the approach of the
landscape blood scheme the policy does
require um
limited landscape harm and this is one
of the more prominent parts of the
allocation so a lot of work has been
done with the applicant and the agent to
get to an acceptable level and
sighting of developments and you can see
here originally there were four
dwellings
right at the top of the site
and this then moved on to three bringing
them down within the site but again
there was still concern over the
prominence
to then ending up where we are and
what's before you today which is two
dwellings very much driven by
landscape impact and design and
these drawings show the relationship
with the
current proposal bonnie haynes to the
west you can see how the development
would sit on
that scheme
um you can see here that actually the
footpath
that's shown on the bunny home scheme
doesn't and connect in with where the
footwear is being shown on this
application
it will be for um
those two footpath connections to be
made to work there will be
um
it's likely that the the more
straightforward it would be for the
bunny homes party to simply connect up
to that top corner but there are ways of
doing that
and
and then the drawing on the right hand
side also shows the bunny home scene in
the context of the bakery states in
below to just give the feel for that
that wider allocation that is certainly
under construction on that southern
section
and finally so just running through the
main planning considerations which are
obviously
set out in g7 core 10 for the principle
of development society is allocated for
residential development it is winning
the development boundary so in principle
there is support for residential
development in this location and
policy nor zero seven
um supporting texas seek a comprehensive
approach and
um so far as sharing of infrastructure
and looking for pedestrian connectivity
um
content that there is a comprehensive
approach as was intended by that that's
that's part of the supporting text
bearing in mind there is separate land
ownership here
layout design and impact of landscape
character
as i said it is a landscape led design
it's the high quality design which
respects um
sensitive materials quality materials
and the layout has been has been reached
with regards to visual impact of the
dwellings and
setting it into the landscape and using
extensive landscaping to mitigate any
harm
residential amenity there is some
distance between the site and the
nearest residential property um you're
looking at a distance of 30 to 35 meters
dwelling to dwelling with green acres
which is on the other side of pit lane
and roughly 55 meters and 75 meters to
the two nearest properties up in pitt
hill so that's a significant distance
and with the levels involved there's not
considered to be any harm to neighbours
there is a condition recommended for our
construction
and in terms of within the site the
privity screening that's which to be
secured by a condition would address any
overlooking between the two dwellings
access and parking
a single point of vehicular access is
proposed
um
that would achieve 43 meters of
visibility in either direction there's
no objection from the highway officer
the access is considered to be safe and
suitable for pedestrian links that are
proposed also will allow for this
development to connect down to the rest
of the allocation
and so there's no objection in that
sense
the addition of two dwellings on the
highway network it's not considered to
be severe in that
and
and as i said the pedestrian link at the
top of the site was the geographical
agreement
heritage and historic england were
consulted um by virtue of taking um and
the views out and
they declined comments and due to this
development the development
certainly didn't raise objection
there was an archaeology condition as
well but that
the archaeologists have been consulted
drainage i've already run through the
drainage book so that's where a gram
pain condition is prepared for secure
drainage connecting into the wider
infrastructure of north levin
and ecology there is a very detailed
ecology report that supports the
application and a further addendum was
submitted to respond to objections that
have been raised
there would be um again biodiversity on
site it's recommended that
the mitigation measures net gain
measures that are proposed are secured
by a condition
the um the extensive tree plant and the
cops would deliver um some habitat
enhancement and the management
maintenance of that can form within the
legal agreement as well
so finally turning to the planning
balance
and
it's considered there is a benefit from
this proposal of delivering two
dwellings in a sustainable location
that's allocated for residential
development and the economic benefits
that we've come from that during
construction and ongoing in terms of
supporting development
and there is a there is a biodiversity
gain as well which would be a benefit
and the pedestrian link of the north of
the site is considered a benefit as well
as it would enable residents coming up
from ecuador to to access the site to
the west which if approved would include
quite a significant area of open space
um
while there is negative impact as well
highways there's no no harm considered
and
definitely drainage and amenity no harm
there is harm that identified in your
office report in terms of landscape
impact that would be a minor adverse
and long-term impact on the development
in terms of the landscape character and
also
limited harm in terms of loss of respect
from pedro
which would be the bottom
light and
however looking at the tilted balance
and the decision taken must be the
benefits of the team are considered to
outweigh that harm so approval is
recommended subject to the condition of
that out and the subject in the world
thank you helen thank you very much for
that
presentation
[Music]
microphone please if you need to bring
it
[Music]
apologies when he registered we thought
he was going to be here but um for
various reasons he's not said he don't
think his apologies right it wasn't
because he just didn't turn up
thank you ladies and gentlemen for
allowing me to speak my name is joy
smart i am secretary to appleton
residents association
and
i think it's tempting to think that this
application is just about
two houses and on top of the rest of the
pit hill development
that might not seem like very much
um however
there are a number of considerations and
your officer has actually alleviated
some of
our concerns
part of the concern is the fact that um
pitiful development has various reasons
have never been subject to a really
comprehensive coordinating approach
so when the um
the local plan and nor7
was actually put in it does say that
for the development there should be
an access
onto pitt hill
well that's long since got lost there
are now several accesses onto pete hill
which uh those of you that know
potentially
[Music]
it's a very
narrow dangerous lane
um
and
this is going to add another access
and
you would have seen from the mouse the
access
is on a blind corner
which although the traffic at the moment
is limited um with money homes that's
going to get
more
and or there will be another access from
the bunny homes development
the question would be is there any
reason why
the access to this development shouldn't
take place or be rooted through
funny homes
which will get me with at least one
extra access point i'm also interested
and perhaps
go to some point clarify
what is the difference between france
and encasing the edge
and removing it and there was talk of a
lot of translocation and in that
particular area with that particular
field and that particular name
we're losing hedges at a scale rate
so the other thing is about the
pedestrian access and i
listen carefully and with interest to
what your officer said because uh where
the access for the pedestrian route
comes out of bangkok at the moment as
you said it doesn't actually link up so
that is a concern especially if it means
taking out yet another or translocating
yet another piece of hedge at the top
there so that is a concern
uh looking at your office's presentation
and thinking that this needs to be the
same
access for people coming from burning
homes and down into apple
we
need to make sure that the access is
actively through the gates abroad and
that the service is appropriate
[Music]
which your officer has
explained i am concerned that that isn't
actually on the application of movement
in the public domain
and i am also concerned uh about the
ownership
according
[Music]
um but that might mean that it takes
another two years before you actually
get full title so um it might move in
planning terms that this might not be
reliable
so uh
thank you
thank you thank you for your
contribution i mean i think all the
members of the committee
and the planning office that have had
yeah this note from uh
keith goodwin
listing only more or less
than all the issues that we've just
faced
[Music]
our next speaker in support of the
application is
[Music]
new three minutes thank you good morning
everybody my name is darren i am the
joint african and they give your support
today please
but my parents and i wish to live
forever family home next to each other
spence finding three generations of
local people
who enjoy making memories and giving our
children the opportunity to play with
their grandma and grandma next door
the house design and all its features
including the access locations
build up construction and soviet by noir
07's planning policy dcc highways
approval and helen's recommendations
i want to remind the committee in terms
of access flaming transport matters matt
collins and bct highways have confirmed
they have no grounds to object and
consider our site to be acceptable
also our new joint joined up access
footpath with bunny hens means all
future pedestrians and cyclists have now
been diverted away far off a pit hill
so they're therefore improving road
safety
exponentially i am a father of three
children who all attend epidural primary
school my wife kerry works in the nhs at
northwest surgery as i was part-time at
the beaver in public village both while
she has helped almost 20 years
i too consider myself an active member
of the labour community i work at the
bottom of pitt hill just off of richmond
road as i am an on-call retained ecuador
firefighter providing 96 hours of cover
it's kian within five minutes of the
station
that said we are both like road users i
cycle walk run to my appointments kerry
energized two days per week after the
school run and we naturally brought the
children to school
my parents now both retired have strong
connections to the village my stepfather
was born in ursula street and his father
the late phillip waters was mayor of
ecuador and a traditional bates building
i wanted to offer up a catchy restaurant
as i'm sure you would all agree being in
a position to build your home with your
family and next to your family and the
village that you live and work in is
everyone's dream as you know the land
was selected by tdc to be built onto its
allocated mountains
over the past 41 months we had submitted
two pre-apps and considered four
different housing variations initially
three conventional houses and five
properties consisting two two beds two
three beds and one and four beds
we then revised it back for three modern
car homes and finally two of the engines
in the day
due to the shape of the field and also
considering visual impact it was
imperative that we were guided by
surveys and helen throughout
lewis and helen have worked diligently
to ensure all teams have crossed and all
eyes were dotted with regards to playing
poverty
so why do you want to me
we all have different reasons
but i'd like to share someone breathing
my parents want to be close to their
grandchildren and enjoy gardening and
caring in danger my six-year-old sophia
wants to have her own bedroom as she
currently shows hours
no one wants to be able to write his
friends but who
zachary our youngest
wants to build down to granddad
and push him down the stairs here's
where it's not mine the people in the
slide
my wife kerry would like open spaces for
the children
and i would like
all of the above and i feel enormously
proud
that we were able to build our dream
energy
[Music]
next speaker is lewis johnson from costa
architects
the agent and supporting the application
have you settled you three minutes as
well thank you for addressing thank
morning my name is lewis and i'm the
director of co-star techs formerly lmr
tech studio and i'm the agent for the
application question the application has
been called in by captain haynes for the
recent set up shortly the first three
point zone will be addressed as the
latter two are not available all other
areas have been addressed efficiently
within the committee report enabling the
case services recommended approval
the application process has taken 15
months and the applicants submitted
their application to comply with every
single request that the planning
department makes
council names point below firstly
recently development given noro7 states
that the allocation should be developed
in a comprehensive manner
following the baker state's approval
tourism sales guaranteed personal
development is unavoidable and a single
coordinated development is on a table if
this argument that peaceful development
would be added to consistently fairly
vague states should never be given
permission as this would be confidence
contracted inhabited development
requesting a continental approach is no
longer a reliable proposition and the
approval of the vapor state student
ahead of the remaining navigation should
not register or influence the saturation
as you'll be aware norfolk inventories
have been enabled for five years online
supply refusing housing from allocated
lands which comply with all other common
policy facing great strength on
unallocated green lands
the second point this development would
create another access from hit hill
effects and traffic congestion safety on
an hour lane
our response uh immediately highways uh
made the ultimate decision regarding
highway safety and mountain collins was
accepted into point of access which has
been revised from his campaign calling
to sit closely alongside the outfit
and prevent a new access from the
further lane
comments regarding traffic and
pedestrian safety
given the new pedestrian
[Music]
which cuts out the entirety of the lane
preventing users from having to walk
along hypno at all and consequently
the application will in fact increase
pedestrian safety
the application will be refused
the applicants are giving over a portion
of their hands why the public benefit
thirdly and finally black green
infrastructure contrary to noro7
green infrastructure requires the entire
allocation it states more a7 should
provide areas of green infrastructure
providing opportunity for biodiversity
enhancement and foreign recreation which
vapor states provide commensurates
besides their development
this application enhances the poor
semi-improved grass and through 74
meters eaten rich hedgerow and 850
meters squared of native tree planting
performing costs
over both the planning forces in divine
justification objectives
with the allocation of wider refers to
leaving more houses for local people
however when a generation of families
with history of all faith building and
our industry seek to build high quality
and sailor towns and village this point
is contradictory
disregarded thank you
finally uh board member councilman
good morning councilman
[Music]
um
yeah the previous speaker saw the
melissa in the recent i have been
calling i must apologize i think the
last two
um
had a brainstorm they don't actually in
terms of affordable housing i suspect it
doesn't apply to the site given they're
in the 2000
i apologize about but my main points
concern access for pedestrians and
traffic really
as you've said um as has been said i
won't go over all of it i mean this
development bears all the hallmarks of
the very importantly considered
allocation of the whole nor7 site
it adversely affects the character of
the countryside and involves elimination
of park
thick hill part of pit hill whilst
leading to inevitable further traffic
impact on the remainder of that lane
instead of the comprehensive
developed development of the sites
required under the policy nor7 a number
of peace deal developments have been
allowed and proposed the previous
speaker suggested that nothing can be
done about it
um the previous um member of the public
who opposes this development has
suggested that that's not the case and
so do i
we're dealing you know with the effect
on the public we're dealing with highway
safety here and it's really important we
get it right
um
regarding the proposed access to the two
dwellings
the as has been fair then a no seven
specifies that highway improvement
should be part of a comprehensive
development
instead of that we've got a separate
access
which kind of goes into the proposed
development
um and as has been suggested we consider
that that access should be part of the
comprehensive development um within the
proposed
nextdoor site the honey homes
um if you allow a second access in on
pit lane into this development
and as we say that will add to the
pressure from trash from traffic
entering pit lane and it's inevitable
that traffic will be going to apple door
from all these new developments um
i personally won't walk along getting
any more apart from the visual
dispiriting visual aspects of the new
developments i wouldn't want to
i wouldn't want to go along there in
terms of being affected by fast moving
traffic on a very narrow lane
um i sort of questioned whether you know
people would want to take their children
walking along that lane to school
or anymore with all these developments
um i
i submit also that this is against the
policy dm 05 regarding highway safety
um
[Music]
i should also mention policy no r7
satisfies there should be minimal impact
on the landscape and sometimes suggest
that the removal of a large section of
entrance to create access would have an
adverse visual impact
i also suggest that there will be a
reduction in biodiversity
i
i recognize that there will be a
translocation of pedro but to actually
remove the hedgerow which has been there
possibly in the hundreds of years um
it's going to have quite an effect on
biodiversity
and if that access was actually put into
the valley home side i don't think it
would have such an impact on
wildlife
or on the landscape
um
given this
satisfaction situation concerning access
i suggest that you defer consideration
of the application until an arrangement
must be made with bunny homes to
allow vehicle access within their site
i also raised the matter of pedestrian
cycle provision which has been raised
the applicant has proposed a pedestrian
path as you know at the top of the site
i suggest this path would have a
relatively minor effect of avoiding the
need for pedestrians to walk along a
stretch of pit lane
um
and more unfortunately this prevention
provision would not deal with danger
from traffic to pedestrians and also
cyclists of course
walking along the left the rest of the
lane to ecuador
this is uh as you know residents locally
that would say fundamental objection to
all this the effects on deep blame
um
my comment is that this path provision
is unsatisfactory because it relies on
the application of the neighbouring
bunny homes development being approved
this therefore leaves really unresolved
the ability of the applicant to provide
a part of the proposed enabling
development at the moment the root of
the past stops at the boundary of the
application site because the rest of the
route into the proposed neighbouring
site is not secured
surely this is not an acceptable
situation in planning terms
it's all despite impossible i mean it
will rely on somebody home scheme
approve
um probably it will be but it's still
not a good planning situation i don't
think
my further comment it's not clear um
whether the path proposed path will be
been wide enough to allow for cyclists
as well as pedestrians
um and this not so will be contrary to
dmo5 again about safe cycle provision
um we've been told the surface of the
park will be i think shippings well is
that suitable for cycling
um
also
about the gate which would go into the
bunny home side um
i thought it was suggested it would be a
kissing gate in which case that would
not allow access to cyclists
or for example from others with crams
um
i think i read somewhere on this
application or the bunny homes one that
there's so it would narrow in order to
stop tractors going through or something
well i think you need to get all this
right really
also
the access onto pit lanes what what sort
of gate would that be would it be a barn
gate or what
um
joining the park with the bunny home
site will also involve removal of the
substantial area page once again i
submit this as concrete policy about
loss of landscape character
um
i also
note that the room proposed to the park
and the application before you
is not marked on the same route as the
one composed of bunny homes
certification i may be wrong there but i
think that's what i think
um
the other point i need to make on that
is that
there would be no direct and safe access
from the um
from this application side and they got
the two houses
along to the um
to the playground
on the neighbouring site they would have
to go
up the road and go up alongside pit lane
and join the park
um i submit again with this
um
the the issues involved with this
proposed part
that because there are things hanging in
the air they need to be resolved and
that is a reason for deferring this
application again
um
just conclude really given the matters i
forget we raise regarding highways
access safe travel provision landscape
impacts and biodiversity loss
i request that you defer further
consideration of the application until
the important matters i've raised are
resolved by the application
thank you councillor haynes
captain mccoy
yeah thank you chairman i hope they're
going to bring a little bit of
insights listening i'm going to oppose
we approve this
application and i'm going to propose
re-approve the application uh my reasons
being um
the long-term
view of the county council is the
bottler pit lane will be closed off to
vehicular access it will be pedestrian
and cycle route only
which supports this
and what obviously when baker estates
first phase is developed the traffic
will be diverted through baker estates
no it's not not matthew collins dealing
with that i see county and shaking set
but i'm more welcome to afford it onto
benzene which proves that the department
pit lane will be close to vehicular
access and it comes into pedestrianized
well i'm not asking you to you've had
your turn sir
so we're opposed to supposedly accept
this thing i'm more happy to send the
paperwork over to you it's supposed to
automatically consultation bring matt
collins as in tony robbins as well so i
will follow that on to you if you have a
look at it um what i'd like to say about
being mindful of the neighbors
opposite was the green acres there i
think the access itself
going into the site we'll talk about
bunny homes i'm not here to talk with
bunny hounds i'm here to talk about the
application before us that moment
there's a plan
committee
not here say what's going to be
happening in the future that's not
unfortunate we can't be deliberated on
that moment and that doesn't sway my
decision whatsoever i don't know who
buddy owns are
not this application this application on
its own
but i would like being mindful that the
neighbors
uh green acres there for obviously any
traffic coming into the site you know i
know we have a detailed plan going
forward and the construction management
plan which i think at the moment bakery
states have had a few little on their
site obviously you know we have to keep
it
up to date with this construction
management plan because you know the
same with downton hill unfortunately
some of the developers aren't they dear
into this and tolerate enforcement
they're going down there too
but this is the main concern this is
planning as well the main concern for
residents obviously you know we have to
abide by this
um no i think that the sighting of the
the accident i'm not the expert the
highway is the expert on the sales but i
think the sighting of the access down
the bottom in the future reference would
become
okay because you wouldn't have to
vaguely access coming through then only
your bigger access coming into the site
but objective view of it was to be
closing off the bottom of pit lane first
so it's actually pedestrianized and
cycled
so i'll stick with my thing but closing
thank you councilman councillor watson
yes chad
not much more to say than that what uh
what councilman just said i uh i will
second this proposal
and yes we are not looking at
the bunny
this is what we're looking at is two
hours
and i'm bringing the body site into it
and everything else i just think we can
you know so yeah i've
seconded it
thank you councillor watson
um
but from my view if you look this
application's been on the go since 2021
and if you look at the history of it
there's been an awful lot of work done
to get to where we are today for two
dwellings
from four down to three noted two moved
down that slope
uh i mean for me a very large
enhancement to the biodiversity that
corpses to be planted and i think
they've done an awful lot of work
to satisfy the some of the issues that
have been raised in the past
it is part of the allocated nr
r7 site
um
and i've got it i give it my whole heart
and support i like the look of the
dwellings
they're set down in the landscape
um
from the viewpoints that were put in
with the application
it's not going to affect anybody at all
the issue of traffic on pit then pet
is a separate issue away from the site
i've always advocated they should make
it one way coming up from
all of the hill with us as i said a
separate matter
so um unless anybody else wants to have
councillor
yeah um
i
i've sat here
quite a few years now
and
i heard both the actor well he calls
himself joint advocate not on my agenda
as an actor
and the agent both say he's going to be
family homes i don't see anyone here
these are local needs houses these are
open market houses whatever you say
uh
i'm told these are within the
development boundary of ecuador
and i have to remind councillors when
the local plan was adopted only two
porridge councillors voted against it
and i was one of them so i'm not bound
by that local plan i can actually talk
about this
and what amazed me when i looked at this
when i looked at the plan why nobody's
raised the issue this isn't the open
country side and before people say oh no
it's right next to mistake it's isn't my
mind goes back to londonderry in a bit
of where we had almost exactly the same
application we had three houses next to
londonderry great huge estate three one
three houses next to it we voted against
it it went to appeal and inspector
turned it down so
i i feel very strongly that this is
nibbling away
at the open areas
left in april and i i'm afraid i don't
know
[Music]
i just want to correct you that you are
bound by the world
in planning
even though even
[Music]
consideration of all the facts in the
area for housing development and that's
exactly what we're looking at can i just
come back you can come back the reason i
voted against the local plan i could see
these issues coming
all these little bits have squeezed in
after this star thing and all the
landlords
[Music]
this is another one i'm sorry but
right it's been moved by councilman got
certainly about council of watson to
approve this can you take the book
please
thank you chair councillor brown
councillor christie
cancer craigie or pencil harding for
counseling let them go counseling
paul counselor newton four pencil watson
four pencil wiseman
that's eight for chair and one against
thank you stanford
[Music]
now if everybody's comfortable at the
moment
we'll
deal with your next advocate
that
but make it breathe
on pages 114
please
[Laughter]
[Music]
the application speeds the definition of
the existing dwelling and the
replacement rating
for new energy efficient pounds
associated landscaping
the application site is number fortune
through stalingrade
uh the application was called in to
communicate uh raising concerns
regarding the sustainability uh
as
[Music]
potential
[Music]
is
[Music]
so the location found before you show
uh the cycling steps within the built-up
form of apple wall are situated on
standard road the site forms a corner
plot that benefits from the provision of
amble um industries great provision of
off-road parking they've also
benefited with a brilliant
extension and a terrace
platform as well as a detached
garden and attach the irish story
[Music]
before you show the existing street
scene
along the stanley road with the
principal elevation as well as views
towards the main road within which
standard rate comes across
here's some further streets in the views
of the western gateway end of the
existing property
maybe
[Music]
as well as a principle as well as the
principal elevation and wide abuse
towards the a1b in the landscape
before you hear
the rear elevation of the existing
dwelling showing the existing terrace
and uh extension as well as a view from
the terrace looking southwards
before you here's now a rear elevation
from the mainland property number 41
stand road
as well as a view from their terrace
just to show the eastern boundary of the
site the site does benefit from a
topography that slopes from north to
south
before you here is the uh proposed rock
band which shows the orientation of the
dwelling uh which will uh maintain the
continuity of the built ball from
stalin road
uh
[Music]
is approximately 108 square meters and
the replacement weight
would be approximately 126 square meters
[Music]
and
passive gain through windows
so here is the south southern rear
elevation which shows the existing
property as against the proposed as you
can see how this reveals the two-story
element of the property which also
benefits and utilizes uh grassroots
feedback or sleep pathology as well as
thermal cleaning and
[Music]
[Music]
foreign before you here shows the
eastern elevation of the existing
property as well as the proposed
scheme the scheme will have no openness
on that eastern elevation furthermore
there will be
a previous previously with a proposed
terrorist career as well as additional
uh timber defense family treatments
before we now show the existing and
proposed weapon elevations
so the first proposed
[Music]
[Music]
mentioned later on
concerns relation consultation regarding
uh glare from the proposed western gable
on technology therefore
[Music]
it shows you the existing floor plan as
against the proposed drawback
[Music]
now shows that proposed landscaping and
boundary treatments that will serve the
dwelling along the eastern boundary will
be a change in terms of the removal of
the detached garage that formed about
and treatment that will be replaced with
the meeting defencing furthermore to
protect the community of moving
properties so
the occupiers uh a 1.7 symbol privacy
screen and illustrated on the patch
will be installed
furthermore the southern elevation below
there illustrates the old pedestrian
access all along that instant boundary
and view from the garden
so to summarize as uh all the details
unlock some report the material
considerations
are principal development
the site is already
at the same
[Music]
the redevelopment of an existing site
and therefore provides a long-term high
quality design that's sought to mitigate
an adaptive technical platform going
forward by the use of
a high quality design that adopts type
of house principles to the use of
renewable energies to subsidize the need
for
finance resources
character
and appearance
there's the former maximum
the design of the proposal sits well
within the context of the surrounding
streets theme uh it
brings in alignment with existing
neighboring properties and the
reveals itself as a single story
dwelling which is characteristic
[Music]
furthermore as already mentioned on the
western label to protect the wider
protective
landscape from any glare from the scheme
that the western gable trains is
conditioned to be over out of their
grazing
immunity concerns uh to mitigate those
concerns raised during the consultation
uh
1.7 privacy screen has been installed
to provide that
protection there furthermore to mitigate
the service during the construction
demolition phase the hours of
construction deliveries have
also been restricted
uh it's also to make those concerns
regarding disturbance or
potential harm to the
third parties property from excavation
work
this is the map that pulls outside of
the material considerations
[Music]
um engaged in writing with the third
party
um
environmental impact
there was concerns regarding the
potential for hazardous materials uh to
be exposed during the demolition such as
the status therefore has been
conditioned as a pre-commencement
condition to secure the investigation of
what materials could be present and to
detail their removal and disposal by
licensed
bodies
uh highways there was concerns regarding
the reorientation of the drone which uh
reduced the visibility on stadium road
this acknowledged that the road stuck um
is utilized np prepares through as the
school run and therefore is a well-used
road
although there's the orientation will
reduce the visibility there still is a
maintained six meter separation from the
highway on the bench see the proposed
built ball and
the harlow officers
who delegated uh standard advice from
myself the officer to apply and in this
instance there would not be a severe irs
safety
on
ecology highlighted there would be no
movement further surveys and therefore
it survives uh to follow mitigation
measures
within the report
therefore i would like to complete the
applications um
advanced with approval
in general thank you
thank you for that concentration on the
bill
um
my first contribution to this is from
david and karen nelson which is
we would like to first thank the
committee for providing us with the
opportunity to have our concern paired
naturally we would have much preferred
to appear before you in person but as we
remain in government service board we
currently
are unable to attend
we note with some surprise that the
committee report already dated the 28th
of july 2022 for this meeting was
published and posted on the tvc website
some days ago
the report reads quite frankly like a
completed minute are we to conclude then
the granted planning permission is a
foregone conclusion to a layman it's
certainly seen things
nevertheless we have outlined a few of
our outstanding concerns below in the
hope that they will be considered
environmental impact on mitigating
climate change
regarding the principles of sustainable
development we find that the demolition
of the residents that 43 stanton road
and rebuilding the proposed design will
contrary to the prudent use of resources
and minimization of waste and pollution
generate a great deal of unrecyclable
and recyclable waste some of which is
very likely to contain dangerous
functions
i refer to the committee i refer the
committee to today's committee report
policy fto2 d
opportunity for renewable low carbon
energy generation whilst conserving and
enhancing the natural and built
environment
e
redeveloping previously developed land
and reducing reusing and recycling
resources
including construction materials
providing the more efficient use of
facilities and enhanced opportunities
for east banking
we
like so many torrid side households have
been recycling our everyday waste for
decades as part of the collective human
effort to reduce our impact on the
natural environment
similar to torridge district council's
stated policy we have strived to embrace
and employ the principle of zero waves
specifically to maximize recycling
minimize waste reduce consumption and
ensure that products are made to be
reused repaired or recycled back into
nature or the
marketplace yet
with this single demolition council
adherence to those principles is
rendered suspect even meaningless
how can you as local government possibly
ask residents to embrace recycling and
throw away left it would not be
unreasonable for anyone to ask what's
the point of conserving pounds and
ounces of material when you literally
allow tons of unrecycled waste
to be generated in a single demolition
in any case to be clear no other
property owner in our neighborhood seems
to have deemed it necessary to generate
so much waste and pollution by
completely demolishing a relatively
young 50 year old dwelling
indeed all the key issues identified as
reporting the demolition and rebuilding
of the dwelling in the architect's
sustainability note of the 6th of june
2022
are by no means unique to number 43
they are common to the overwhelming
majority of homes in staten road and
surrounding areas
yes though many others seem to have
managed to renovate and upgrade their
property to very reasonable standards
without finding it necessary to demolish
their entire property
of course we recognise that developers
can achieve significant cost savings by
avoiding value-added tax on labour
materials
and new build projects such as the one
being proposed whereas most homeowners
would have to get by paying the added
costs of refurbishing rather than
rebuilding
given the increased demand for and
scarcity building material
particularly in light of the current
economic and political climate the
proposal clearly fails to meet the
principles of sustainable construction
indeed rather than embracing the
principles of sustainable development
council approval of this and similar
proposals will inevitably set a
precedent in further demolition and
rebuild
generating ever-increasing waste for
landfill and placing greater burden on
both the market for raw materials and an
environment already under tremendous
threats under no circumstances can be
viewed as the prudent use of resources
amenity
considerations rather than following the
natural curvature of certain roads like
the existing dwelling the proposed
dwelling for crude without modification
will stick in an east-west orientation
in line with our dwelling we feel that
the taller proposed design will result
in significant overshadowing and lots of
light to the western side of our house
in the afternoons and evenings our
living dining room currently enjoys the
benefit of natural light from a west
facing floor-to-ceiling window on this
side of the drilling
we feel this will be significantly
diminished if the dwelling is
constructed from proposed position and
orientation
with the proposed removal of the garage
and reorientation of the main structure
it appears that the height position and
orientation the proposed deck the rear
eastern side of the dwelling will allow
occupants a commanding view over the
rear of our lane as well as the entire
rear garden which lies at a much lower
level
this will cause a total loss of privacy
we note that the applicant's architect
has since revived the plan by proposing
the erection of a 1.7 metre primitive
screen on the eastern side of the death
area
in the event that the screen is
permanently installed and remains in
position then our concerns in this area
are mitigated
a further issue of concern for us is the
drainage system the drains from number
43 cross our property and join the local
water authority drainage system at an
inspection chamber in the southeast
corner of our rear garden
recently we have been informed that the
previous owners of our property were
required to grant access to drainage
engineer on february occasions in order
to clear blockages in number 43 strains
given that the proposed larger dwelling
is designed to support increased
occupancy we remain concerned that the
existing drainage system is insufficient
for the increased size of the property
construction disturbance
as depicted in the planning application
demolition of the existing garage is
proposed after which the ground adjacent
to the property boundary will be
excavated to a yet unknown death to
accommodate the foundation of the
proposed dwelling
a retaining wall of brave perfect is
proposed
nevertheless
there's no point of order
there is a point in water because the
public speaks in three minutes i'll deal
with that and this is going on way too
long it's abusive
it is clear that the intention is to
excavate well below the foundation
levels of our dwelling and as those
excavations will come as close as 1.2
meters to our foundation
therefore we remain seriously concerned
that proposed excavations will disturb
the foundation of our home and cause
structural damage to the dwelling
specifically unless measures are taken
to immediately shore up the excavation
any collapse of the ground and can be
witnessed by excavations already taking
place on the opposite side of 43 stone
roads will likely cause substance and in
turn
damage to our property foundation
also the noise and mess generated will
likely be a continuing disturbance to
our neighbours and ourselves for months
on end and will severely restrict the
amenity of our properties
an additional ongoing concern
caused the concern the traffic situation
on this particular corner of southern
road the area of the popular parking
area for parents with children attending
ecuador primary school
sadly even at the best of times while
there's often approachable in the road
without anticipating the obstructions
that typically lay ahead
we recognize that this problem falls
outside the agreement committee which
should demolition construction be
approved we can expect a hazardous road
safety condition with severe disruptions
to traffic in the many months the
demolition and real rebuilding process
will endure
thank you i'm gonna say i've got
i'm fed up with some of these landing
letters and helen and i discussed it
before the meeting got out of the way i
think we're going to have to restrict
letters
to wanting today for both sides of him
and that
that should fall well within between
that period because
some some members of public writing have
been taking advantage with long worthy
letters like that
very often containing nothing to do with
planning management we haven't changed
yeah i mean some of these people who who
spoke this morning must be
kind of a bit upset about don't want to
say something else but upset about
what's going on well i'm upset about
what's going on because it's people are
taking an advantage
uh right okay we'll move on because our
next
contributor to this application
is
karen traynor in support with the agent
[Music]
uh thank you
and i'll try and keep it brief
and
as andre stated and the design i think
and part of the concern that the
um the objectives has is was around
excavation as anthony says this isn't
really a matter of safe routine that's
[Music]
report uh
pretty much on all fronts and policy can
climb and so therefore we deem it to be
a sustainable and sympathetic design
that can only enhance um apple driving
in the wider community yes it is a
slightly contemporary take on a
um a very traditional area and but going
back to the sustainability design we've
done lots of research and
looked into this further
and
just to put it into perspective uh the
50 year old property is coming to what
would be the life cycle of a house
and it is it's
quite rickety it has seen better days
and as with all new houses they need to
be into a sustainable
sustainable design and upgraded in order
to keep people
rising energy costs to keep people
in a comfortable environment and
so in typical senses that that on a kind
of an average house on um the old
building regulations uh two months ago
and it would take roughly knock down a
house to build a new one it takes
roughly 34 years of the carbon and
that's operational for carbon and body
carbon to be
payback period essentially
and now obviously what we're proposing
here is a
there's a lot higher standard building
that payback is going to come down
significantly then out on top of that
the renewables that we're adding the ssc
pump and
the functionality of the house and then
that again is
substantially decreased so in
in reality in terms of carbon and that's
a good good base system to
address sustainability as a whole
because that's a benchmark that
everything applies to
and
this will be in town then looking at the
lifespan of the building which is 60
years plus
and by the time you get around to sort
of in 20 years time 2030 time the
building would have rent paid back its
carbon than their current house and
that's like say just on the basis of
of figures based on the average homes in
the uk and this is going way above and
beyond and in terms of means and i think
we've shown through the foundation of
supporting some information that
and it's impossible to i guess
do any construction in a slightly
built-up area and not have some impact
on immediately that's unless you feel
nothing then that's obviously going to
have some sort of impact whether it be
dust noise or something and again with
the
officer's report and conditions a lot of
the movement of traffic and some of the
other concerns i think we
have highlighted is additional screening
and the existing sort of terrorist level
is at the same level as the composed in
in a broadly roughly same location with
no real change
access and
front garden access has been improved
there's more turning more turning areas
a larger area additional car parking
spaces
and
yes we get to
and garden itself and we're proposing uh
some defenses and also enhancement in
terms of biodiversity with with
additional planting and and drainage and
that and drainage is going to connect
into the additional network
and although there is a slight
in output if you like that this is
relatively insignificant into like an
initial toilet and
yeah and
yeah and in terms of
form and scale and
again broadly from the diagrams you can
see the drawings it already keeps in
keeps in line with the
the street scene and also the local area
although we are going off slightly we're
only level with the neighboring
thanks for properties
time
thank you very much thank you on my
money timewise
around you a little bit
thank you
you're watching
[Music]
yeah notwithstanding your comments about
the long neck so i hope you took on
board on the epic of what the objective
said and so very valid points
no thank you
i refer to policies in the national
planning framework and the local plan
for your consideration when discussing
the application before you to demolish
this property i also refer to this
council's declaration of climate
emergency in its commitment to next zero
carbon emissions by 230
regarding the national planning
framework please note para154 stating
development should avoid increased
vulnerability to the range of impacts
resulting from climate change
local planned policy sto2 concerning
mitigating climate change states that
the development is expected to make a
positive contribution towards social
economic and environmental
sustainability
while minimizing its environmental
impact under clause b it stated there
should be a prudent use of resources
local planned policy sto5 concerning
sustainable construction requires the
development to minimize the consumption
of resources during construction
i submit the application to polish and
demolish a bungalow at stadton road and
to build a replacement contravenes these
policies demolition would waste the
embodied energy in the bungalow and
replacement would release carbon
emissions through the manufacture and
transport materials and the construction
process
in the absence of any information from
the applicant the materials from the
demolished fungal will be reused then i
also submit the disposal of these
materials and replacement would further
out to carbon
emissions involved in the development
on this issue i refer to local plant
policy dmo3 regarding waste
the applicant has claimed the existing
building is environmentally inefficient
and is listed a number of reasons in
support of this statement
in assessing these reasons may i suggest
some of them should be instantly
dismissed as irrelevant i refer to the
assertion that the wiring heating and
telecommunications arrangements are
outmoded that the sanitary wearing quick
kitchen equipment needs modernization
and that some rooms are poorly lit
shawlee councillors these are not
reasons to demolish a building
as for the remaining matters listed the
energy inefficient wall stores windows
and heating which the applicant refers
to will be dealt with by upgrading the
existing building
i therefore seriously question the
applicant's claim that the new building
would be more energy efficient
no carbon audit of the existing bubble
has been supplied including figures of
the net carbon saving from adapting the
building to be more energy efficient for
example by exterior cladding new windows
floor insulation and the heat pump
no figures have been supplied either on
the carbon emissions associated with
demolition or the replacement building
the applicant refers to the new building
as high quality and sustainable and are
designed towards passive house
principles
that there is no indication of what
energy standards would be reached
surely such information should be a
basic requirement in considering the
application and given the planning
policies i've referred to
i also raise other other concerns about
the application i submit the noise dust
and pollution involved in demolition and
replacement would have an unacceptable
impact on neighbours thus going against
local plant policies gmo2 and dm03
and i know that it's been recommended
they start at seven o'clock in the
morning well that's going to be fun then
i also submit the visual impacts of the
proposed building will conflict with the
design of neighbouring properties and
street scene which is made up of mainly
bungalows
i refer you to the objections sent to
you by the cpre that no visual
assessment has been done on the effect
on the neighbouring aonv
in addition our reverse concerns that
the height and orientation of the
building could adversely affect
visibility of the vehicles negotiating
the bend in the road given heavy usage
by traffic and the dense street parking
that occurs when parents deliver and
collect their children from apple or
school
in conclusion councillors i ask you to
give poor consideration to the points
i've raised and in particular the issue
of use of resources in relation to
carbon emissions and climate change
please note that other residents of
similar bungalows in the street have
managed to modify their homes rather
than demolishing them and no doubt they
have incorporated energy efficient
measures in the process thank
that's the last of the contributors for
this application
i will point out that 20 cities didn't
become audible town council on both
occasions they've recommended approval
i mean
well if anybody wants to speak
[Music]
i find it extraordinary that we're
wasting valuable time or the suggestion
that we should be wasting the valuable
time of people such as cpre to
consult on a
unit for unit replacement on a built up
area which is hardly going to have any
impact on the aonb
that is purely a procedural spanner to
try to throw in the cogs of getting it
done the other point i'd make out is
that
demolition yes one understands the the
carbon cost of demolition but it's not
all one way i mean there's any number of
sites which are crying out for crushed
hardcore for footings uh recycle which
by using recycled material saves
actually quarrying more natural material
to to fill that void um
and
also that
we are looking at a
relatively low in modern terms a
relatively low quality build in in
efficiency terms and he's been replaced
by something which is clearly much more
efficient modern up-to-date and future
clinton i mean we're almost talking
about a life building here anyway um so
i would agree with you entirely that uh
i would support this advocate
thank you
nobody else wants to contribute sandra
could you just be
recommended for approval to grant by the
second by council watson
thank you chair
[Music]
right let's move on then so
the next application is application 7d
i'm doing
so the application recording is required
uh one
slash zero one seven one
slash uh twenty three twenty two fbl the
application seeks the direction of the
single dwelling within the rear garden
box and property known as graphene and
parker
the application is the submission of an
earlier scheme
due to the absence of a appropriate
ecology survey retreat survey
and legend test
so as you can see
now is the location plan
so indicating that there's the
development boundary of the site which
stiff is the lower however the virtual
energy photos is a former orchard that
serves the residential property
record
which is outlined with the blue edge as
well
and some areas you can see the
neighboring properties that are bound to
more east and south
and
before you hear the existing streaks
theme of the property so as people make
the existing property in front of you
and then the post access is just to the
left of the
some further garage that show a close-up
of the post with the existing site
and propose access
[Music]
so photos before you are from um
earlier this year and uh
recently showing the real existing
dwelling at the site
as well as uh photos of the garden that
will be retained
existing dwelling as well as
uh going around sort of southern the
lower part of the site where the
development boundary is proposed
so this is the boundary that would so
from the south
is uh photos of uh from the eastern
boundary
showing the site
before you hear the top photos showing
the southern boundary which is a mixture
of uh
mature trees to uh more than single
fence
and also more
it's uh
lower level which in defense
so before he here's the site plan the
site of the access from the highway to
north
that is to be noted that the access
has raised concerns
[Music]
the scheme will be orientated
approximately north to south but at a
site angle the principal elevation forms
where the uh calm plan is located and
the rear will be to the south
a number of trees within the site will
be removed but they are mainly the
former apple trees the ones of most
significance will be retained and that
will be detailed on the latest line
the steam will require the diversion of
the bowel uh
sewer pipe to connect into southwest
water mains height
this will be achieved by an intimate
agreement with between japan and
southwest waterfalls outside the
application
as proposed to the
dwelling as well
[Music]
so before you here shows the principal
elevation to the left and the rear
elevation to the right
and these show both the side elevations
so if it's found in the east side of the
west
and here shows raw pile as a dwelling
which will provide a three-bedroom
single storey property
before you hear um
it details the true protection plan and
the summary notes of the tree collection
measures that have been adopted
the significant choice of importance the
distances are particularly on the
southern boundary where there's some
mature ashrae
the scheme has been amended accordingly
during the consultation
feedback from parish council and navy
properties regarding concerns
of construction works within proximity
and maybe
trees within the site and the joining
um
and a super art cultural sort of
assessment that is reflective of the
trees and sites that would be
potentially impacted by the application
considerations in this instance the
spike is set within the developed form
of parker within the development
boundary and it's
there are concerns regarding the nature
of the proposal in terms of
uh
what was referenced as factual lands
background development nonetheless each
scheme is considered on its
own merits
demonstrate how the scheme can function
independently from
the existing dwelling on the site as
well as how it will relate to the
surrounding properties
in terms of character and appearance the
scheme is of the single story nature
which is
within which is considered appropriate
how to integrate potential overbearing
harm to enabling properties that
within the vicinity of the site that
range from shallow boundaries of the
story nature to some story dwellings
to the south
the scheme will also provide that
boundary treatments that provide a
better immunity relationship so around
the southern eastern and northern
boundary there will be
1.8 in the fence
sufficient privacy boundary between the
proposed site enabling properties by
screen predominating all openings that
would come from a single storm
development
uh to protect that character and
uh permitted development rights have
been revoked to ensure that first floor
extensions would be facilitated that
could result in any character or
immunity harm
in terms of other immunity
considerations
the hours of construction and deliveries
have been proposed to be conditioned as
per the environmental protection
officer's promise to mitigate harming
some northern property during that
construction phase
highways and during the consultation
concerns revealed regarding the proposed
access to the site it is acknowledged
that this
proposed access is 2.8 meters and falls
below highway standing device with three
meters
therefore i consulted these two
highways and my income provided
prominence that acknowledged the
concerns for gut rates
nonetheless there was no evidence to
suggest that it would
propose any unsafe highway access
in this instance
environmental impact there's an
unforeseen contamination condition
attached to the scheme
and as already mentioned in terms of the
power drainage it would connect into a
main sewer um there were concerns with
greater garden capacity without drainage
through the treatment part standing left
southwest water were consulted and
raised no objection to this scheme
in terms of diverting
uh an existing power
sewer line through the site to connect
them to the main line uh that is an
agreement that stores outside of this
application to be secured with the
southwest water elsewhere voters
amusement agreements
uh concerns were raised regarding the
subway's location depth and potential
for landslide
the scheme that's been
the sake away has been um
undergoing when perpetuation tests to
demonstrate the ground and suitable
means of absorption um
and is sighted within the appropriate
distances and separation and
there was concerns that the
height of it would be above the finished
floor levels but it's the cycling
details it will be lower and also to
note that the specific technical details
would be captured during a building
regulations assessment
uh in terms of ecology it highlighted
there was potential from uh harms and
nesting bursts and therefore detailed
litigation measures have been
applied and conditioned
and furthermore that gaming measures
will be
um captured through uh wrecking third
box and
hedgehog elegance
therefore i would recommend this the
application is approved
[Music]
thank you
yesterday the first speaker was coming
speaking against it
emailed me with
this
have everybody seen that and i asked him
to email the rest of the committee
and
to help him
i think this will help because there's
an issue out there
but i think can
you try and shoot it's council hardiness
women
i don't know we don't usually hand out
documents
during the
contribution stage but this is just a
plan
and a plan i think that's very useful
uh when you're considering the context
of this application so our first speaker
who's speaking against his member of the
public is david butler
what you said
[Music]
good morning everybody
if planning permission is granted
there will be severe and unnecessary
impact upon the garden could be joining
property
namely the moorings
as a result of the oversized build for
this particular plot
complicated by two existing sewers
and tree root preservation zones
so what exactly is the impact on the
moorings
well the most recent plan devised by the
architects
and now accepted by surplus water is to
relocate the existing sewer
that runs across the whole of the rear
garden and the moorings
and replace it with a new section of
sewell
this will involve digging some 25 meters
of trench one and a half meters deep yes
installation of a new inspection chamber
and 10 meters of trench connecting the
moorings or reconnecting the moorings to
the diverted stool
how certain is it that the mooring sewer
will need to be relocated
well there are three pieces of evidence
firstly the proposed sewer fruit
suppression that proposed rooting of
sewer across the garden in the mornings
is clearly shown on the architects plan
secondly i have spoken with the planning
department in southwest water
and they have confirmed that the
proposed routing of the sewer is
acceptable from their standpoint
furthermore they have statutory rights
to locate sewers whether wherever they
deem necessary
and thirdly the proposed bill has
insufficient garden space around it to
accommodate the sewers and to comply
with the southwest waters regulations
within its boundary
furthermore two other important factors
which are not being taken into account
within the submission
the first is that the new so within the
moorings will go through the middle of a
soak away
and secondly that the new cell within
brecken is within a tree root protection
zone which has been emitted from the
survey
in summary
there is no conceivable need to change
the location of the ser within the
mornings indeed it would be perfectly
possible for a new smaller bill to
comply with southwest water regulations
but
certainly not the planning application
which you have in front of you
if running permission is granted the
residents of the moorings will be forced
into accepting a new sewer being
installed across their garden to
facilitate the proposed bill
this is unacceptable as the warrant
should not suffer for the sake of this
plan thank you chairman
thank you
our next speaker against this is
handcheck corbett
[Music]
position here i don't want to say good
morning or good afternoon so i'm going
to say good day
um thank you thank you chair my name is
anthea omar
and i am reading this on behalf of
christine battle of the moorings who
because of disabilities and covered
cannot attend in person
she says the following i right to object
to this planning proposal being the
immediate next door neighbor
i am disabled with serious mobility
issues which mean i use an ability
scooter and walking frame
due to being virtually houseband my
garden is my lifeline
mr andrew stevenson consultant
orthopedic surgeon at nuffield health
has stated quote on examination this
lady is barely able to walk and require
the assistance of two people to get to
my couch
end quote and that came from a letter
dated the 7th of july 2022
due to the overbearing size of the build
the routing of the sewer means southwest
water proposed to dig up a large area of
our back garden
as you can imagine this is causing me
mental anguish when i think of the
considerable upheaval involved in this
southwest water proposal
not to mention the impact of the noise
and disruption next door if the build
went ahead it being in such close
proximity to our property
i cannot stress the negative impact this
will have on the quality of my life
and my physical well-being
i therefore request that you refuse this
application
in its current form
thank you listen
thank you
our next speaker in support of the
application is the age of president
and again once you've settled do three
minutes to present and connecting
thank you chairman councillors the
proposed design is a single story
through the bungalow that respects the
scale of the neighborhoods
this ensures that the proposed
development will not be overbearing
the site is well screened by existing
boundaries and mature apartment and as
such there will be no overlooking issues
wedding has been carefully designed to
respond to the shape of the site
and both the new building will have
generous guardians
the founding officer has concerned both
confirmed that he is happy with the both
well invented policy and design in
relation to the neighboring planes
highways have reviewed the access
parking and turning arrangements shown
on plans and have raised no objections
the application initially
received a good number of public
objections
this highlighted that further
information will be required to overcome
these concerns
this additional information included
circulation steps
additional detail on the proposed
boundary treatments clarity on the power
drain connection and pre-service
percolation tests show that the site had
good drainage and will ensure that
surface functions are designed
the additional boundary treatments
include new 1.85
and mixed native hedging both of which
will ensure neighboring properties the
host welding and the proposal to enjoy
private needs and spaces with no
overlooking
southwest water have seen the proposals
have agreed and repositioned faster
which can serve three properties
and have raised their objections
oh's new connection will avoid the rips
and trees and a reposition will be
carried out at the applicant's expense
the tree survey looked at all the
surrounding trees and highlighted a
large ash tree
located in the neighboring garden would
require a protection zone
which three protective fencing will be
positioned shown on plants and remain
penis during construction
following the exchanges and plans
and the additional information signature
the latest round of public consultations
only receive three public receptions
thank you very much
thank you
our final speech for this is board
member canceling the job
[Music]
chair
okay so there have been many concerns
over the course of the application and
most of which have been addressed by
angelo so i thank you very much for his
time on this
and
i do remain concerned about the issue of
the sewer and the re-routine of it
and
even if it is
[Music]
1.5 meters away from the proposed
property which
everyone had a recent application
apartment turned down because
it was too close and that was three
meters
there appeared to be an inconsistent
[Music]
um i must compare with mr mrs
butterworth at the moorings that this
down to the scale and the size of the
bottom
it's not about the commission in
principle for planning here it is the
scale
and
um
does it have to be confederate
surely it can be changed to be more
appropriate
the butterworths will not only have to
endure the destruction of a build
adjacent to their back garden but also
through no fault of their own
have their own garden decimated and
facilitate the re-reaching of the sewer
because frankly a bungalow that is too
large for the site
[Music]
being allowed next one
ahead
this is totally unjust a nature of the
subject they shouldn't be subject to
such stress and upheaval
for someone else's gain the inevitable
mental and physical impact of works on
both of these residents is avoidable
the driveway and the boundary treatment
to the west which is the mornings
are also a concern there is a proposed
wall a local with a fence on top but i i
was unclear
as to the overall height that is going
to segregate the two driveways of that
fence
that goes up on your plans to a group of
trees
and then there is a
smaller 1.3
metre wooden fence beyond those trees
which would effectively
facilitate a view from the proposed
property right into the northern back
garden
and given that angelo has proposed a 1.8
meter fence around all the rest of the
factories
i don't understand why that one's lower
unless i've got that wrong
i did put a call out challenge though
yesterday but it's a bit late in the day
so we haven't conversed on that but i'd
really like to insurance because it
appears that the western dynamic
is going to be more subject to
overlooking
the width the driveway for fire access
albeit the highways don't have an issue
with it
2.8 i thought fire access had to be
three meters
um i acknowledge the principle of
development here indeed as a spectacle i
i believe the scale and design is not it
will result in unnecessary mental and
physical distress for the neighboring
residents in a village which has had a
massive amount of new houses built out
recently
with more on the way it is way over
quota from its requirement of houses
within our local plan
whilst i acknowledge the principle
so ultimately i am urging you
to turn these particular plans down
please do
really ascertain the boundary on the
western side and the height because the
implications to this neighboring
property
are quite considerable
and
thank you
thank
you dell
that's enough contributions there so
okay count council watson and council
chris
just a few things
i'm looking at this drainage system
[Music]
oh
[Music]
what it is angela
is you see
the thick red line
i want to know
does this is does this belong to
southwest water are they main is this
the main drainage sewer basin aware it's
all the pipe work in silver nasal
southwest water this is northwestern
where it's southwest water
that will go
[Music]
i believe it is
[Music]
out of the front here right
uh which goes then follow the the route
down to to get into southwest waters
main train
right
this belongs to to the housing between
the housing and also
it is
you don't need to divert it because if
it goes through that property if it's
encased in concrete that's fine
and i know this because i've done it
and and our building inspector will tell
you just the same so i i just can't
understand that
southwest water
the same vertex there
well in terms of the green roots and
is i appreciate those immunity or
concerned race regarding the
implications associated to the
development but it does actually fall
we
as officers need to be sure of the means
of bowel drainage is
achievable and in this instance it was
proposed to connect to a maintenance
in terms of facilitating that agreement
it goes all outside of the assessment of
the application
in terms of
[Music]
within the development site itself
there was needing to be a repositioning
connection from the existing dwelling to
the sewer line in terms of the
implications beyond that
that it's out and gone
it's out of our control with control of
the application right
it's a facilitated agreement through
southwest winter
so
i've previously mentioned an easement
agreement and that's how it's
discussed
because
i mean i've been
[Music]
because
i would like to know that
if something went wrong with that would
southwest water don't put you tonight no
i don't think so been out to you
right
and and so therefore i i can't see i
can't see what the problem is there at
all
you know
and
for me
um i propose that we have we approved it
and we really do because i can't see any
problem
well i think the officers have
recommended grant i'm going to vote
against this
i'm already very very
wary when we get back land development
by this somebody's got a big guard they
will squeeze in a house
and
always very wary though because they
always have impacts on neighbours
um
what are they made if they've been
highways
who apparently could see no problem with
the really narrow road coming out onto a
quite busy road i've gone on to google
earth i've looked at it you can see it
on our color photocopy
the end of the yellow
bit that comes out onto the main road
it's a huge bush i'm looking at google
earth now it's about 10 foot high
i mean you arrive there you can't
actually see anything you're down county
we have it so many times you've got to
have these huge displays you know
visibility displays this way you can't
see anything you have to see the bush on
our thing i'm just amazed at them
lightweight can't see a problem with
this but i can't see the neighbouring
more in chopping it down
to help visibility
um on that basis alone i think this is
the mad scheme
third point the sewer
i think councillor darts summed it up
why should the moorings suffer
that's the the benefit of their
neighbour to get a you know a big
building site i just find that
incredible uh so i'm going to vote
against this
comes any point of order i think
probably chair or clarification please
technically
is the
physical health
or mental health
of
a neighbor who may be impacted by a
development is that a matter of material
consideration i know in environmental
protection it is not because of a case
that i've got in my own ward at the
moment until we found out that from a
technical point of view and it's not
that i don't have lots of sympathy for
mrs butterworth but from a technical
point of view is that something that we
should be considering or not
um
yes so um i would say you get a limited
weight
in the planning process um whilst you
know every single thing would be held
with
personal circumstances of a neighbor
indeed an applicant we in the planning
process we are assessing against policy
um and and whilst being a material
consideration would be given limited
waves in mind
circumstances of an individual
thank you uh please join us one other
follow-on and just
make a point about these these the these
various trees that we're looking at um
one can see from the aerial view there
to the east northeast there's a uh
which was referred to by angelo a large
ash
um it was dead up up the torrid valley
i'm losing ash at twenty percent a year
at the moment through ash dieback uh
there is an assumption highly likely
that that tree in time will be doomed um
and you know
you would question whether because of
disturbance here it wouldn't be timely
to take it down and replace it with with
something that that's that can get on
and get growing on the other side i see
that especially on this where
prominence has been made of tree root
protection emitted
we seem to be looking at
quite a small crown of what i suspect is
a non-native um uh tree now because they
look like ornamental um
le landai type um pushes down that side
anyway so
um
[Music]
on this part here
it's mulch on there
yes they are for all
i
understand where cancer chris is coming
from uh when you're coming out of this
drive it's not a road actually to drive
with the big bush but when you look at
the moorings
they've got the same problem
right
when they come out of their drive they
have the same problem
this chair i could actually show
councillor watson google earth there is
no well there's a bush showing on the
left of the drive yeah it's not here on
google
[Music]
there is a degree of the additional
visibility
that further furthermore the vehicle
driven screws particularly
which are not once gonna be
achievable speed so generally
it's deemed on balance um the highway
safety was acceptable
in this instance because of those
characteristics
the crowd's dead anyway so yeah
it will not be long before it dies
anyway yeah right let's ask about
angela just said that i mean
constantly when we go to rural side we
talk about visibility strains and yeah
you can see on this photograph there's a
huge push
where that gate is that will be the
entrance to this site oh i'm just amazed
that devon county think that's all okay
and yet and other sites they are so
specific about these huge visibility
space you've got to have
well as angela said i mean that's a
deceptive photograph because it's taking
one it's a straight piece of road there
actually and as you come out there's
quite a wide piece and you can see it on
there
if you came out with a carpet you can
[Music]
and there is an existing driveway in
there
and so anybody could drive in the next
town
more of concern to me is this drainage
issue
um
and i i might not be popular with
officers but i'm gonna recommend this is
deferred
because i think
we need more information i'm agreed i
agree absolutely councillor watson on
this these drains are private they're
all on private land
mine runs into the conservation of the
kitchen and if anything went wrong with
it i couldn't put it right no exactly
not southwest water
they'll only take responsibility for
where it connects to their main drill
yeah so
i think it's a cheap to expect all next
the morning's garden to be able to hook
just what happens about its application
so two things about that more
informational is exactly where these
drains will go and we should have seen
that actually because the applicant
should be putting them on the plant
on their plants and we've not got that
and also i hope there's trees that we're
looking at what are these trees that
need root protection and which trees
you know you're not worried about you
know
i don't want any tree whether it's
whether it's
a native one or a medicine shouldn't
come under threat from
the roots being effective from
development
so those two things as i have more
information
council great
i just feel that
it is a known development of the style
but it would be a you could reconfigure
it
moving it sliding downwards or making it
into a different shape and there's
plenty of room for talk so i don't
really see them in 17 for it to go in
the veins at all
and
could you easily reduce it to a two
bedroom i think you'd better use it and
say we accept the principle of
development
they need to come back with a smaller
and better design
of the actual overload
which would address which could address
the nations of the drains and the
treatment true protection that's needed
on the side
i mean
they're not considered the one in pit
hill that they we just looked at a
little while ago
and to choose where the the
that went in with the applicant to make
it a compliant scheme reducing it from
43 to 2 dwellings and then we've got
this here which has raised a lot of
issues with drainage and treat the trees
on the side
i am
i'm happy to withdraw that we get bit
more information because i think
we we could see a better scheme here
than this
so if you want to make that proposal
then i'm happy to settle in cancer brain
and the main reason would be
lack of information on the drainage for
the site
the tree preservation and the over
development of the study
potential
[Music]
and
we mean certainly
having concern over over development of
a plot
linked with that again is is reasonable
i mean just touching on the drainage
issues as the objects were acknowledged
there there is separate legislation
through the water act for requisition
and
i just just want to highlight members we
need to be careful in terms of
incorporating
something that could be achieved under
separate legislation for planning as a
group of curriculum i just wanted to
highlight that point and we do need a
you know a clear reason for refusal and
and football information
yeah
yeah i i think we should stick with what
you wanted to do if we want a bit more
information just repair it
no not not turning down we've we've been
dancing this route two or three times
and
it's been reduced and then we've changed
it on the same day i think we should if
we're going to do this let's prepare it
for more information about
the the drainage well
there's two issues really that have come
up during the discussion
and that is a council trading council of
christian raids or we did that back to
the site background development all we
developed with the three bed bungalow
the other one is more information about
the drainage and as helen said
um
we can leave we need more information
well i need more information
[Music]
or exactly
is this soundcloud strange there's no i
don't think it is but we don't know for
sure
uh
if it's private that training system
they can do whatever they want yeah it
doesn't claim
[Music]
because i know i've done it at home
um
and then this treat the tree protection
in the area because on this and i don't
know if this is i've not already
introduced it's not accurate what you've
got in front of it it says that there is
a tree with protection
emitting from the survey that um
the assessment that was put in by
these three assessments it's been messed
up
and i don't know what trees do all trees
have to be protected
with development from development um
yeah i mean would we would normally
if there was an arbor or a cultural
survey it would pick out the
trees that were higher quality and
there's various levels of
that they would be prioritized for
protection he wouldn't necessarily
protect ornamental trees for example i
think there is a distinction there
in terms of that level of protection
that you've got planning off the point
of view that you would look to secure i
mean it certainly is open to members to
get more information and certainly as
officers we
all aim to work
proactively and positively in the
solution so that that could give that
opportunity for the case office to at
least clarify those points so you feel
that unless you have all of the relevant
relations before you let's get the
declaring then i think
and then
we'll have it back with more information
and yeah on the issue council president
uh our second against the great appeal
withdrawal of your second one because
she was quite right at pointing out the
principle
okay but if you just defer it with it
we're basically accepting quite a large
plot uh quite a large house on quite a
small plot and i think the over
development issue
needs to be addressed and you can only
really address that by voting against
this and making them come back with a
new application
or they might just go very quickly
nobody
your proposal to defer
so we have councillor craigie proposed
to infuse with his second day
um
so we don't have a proposal to defend
and tell you about the moment unless
councillor craigie and you are going to
agree to withdraw your
proposed reviews
and then if you want to propose to i
will i'm there
i will i will withdraw my protection to
refuse
but that has never been sent by a
council
company will take character craig is
recommendation to refuse the application
we'll need reasons for that
if it goes through exactly
you happy with that you've got that song
because
i don't think that was seconded by
councilman christie before you withdrew
so he counselor christine couldn't
second because he seconded
um
sorry but he did say he withdrew and i
immediately jumped in and said i'll
second it
he did say withdrew
i mean i
[Music]
[Music]
right so this is
this is the vote to refuse the
application
[Music]
that this application is reviewed how mr
christie is second with it can we take a
vote from that uh can we just be careful
on the reason for refusing
the development all the development to
decide
absolutely
[Music]
so cancer brown
cancer christie or
cancer craving or cancer hiding
i'm against refusing him
cancer leather against
cancer mcgrath
four
would i give you one back again
councillor newton against
hansel watson against cancer wiseman
that's
five for refusal and four against the
applications
that's it and that's refused
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah and this is a member of staff our
minute taker just had to wait
while this
[Music]
okay and sarah is going to sarah boyle
is going to present thank you thank you
chair
so the application is for a first floor
extension at the rear of the property
known as certain sunnyside and this is a
resubmission of an application that came
in last year um so as the chair said
this is being brought to the plant
committee because it's a member of
torridge district council
so just a couple of verbal um updates
because obviously of the process of
plans committee um we have received some
more public representations um after the
committee report was um printed
so we've had a support comment from a
councillor mackenzie
and devin from the website um but just
to summarize he basically has limited
support to the planning application and
is aware of the residents who have
applied and has and
kind of what
care they need to provide to the parent
for the reasons of um producing the
plans is that it's a worthy plan that
has been put forward to solve a problem
and not for frivolous reasons the
objections do not fit planning criteria
and should be disregarded in my opinion
and and then the letter of support
just reiterates um some of the points
that are already considered within the
report and so this is from one of the
next door neighbors
and they are looking at kind of access
and works overlooking and privacy
drainage foundations and boundary walls
which a lot of that has already been
covered within within the report
that's the objection
can i just ask
which neighbor is it because this is the
terrace is it yeah so this is the
terrace so um the
objection comment has come from 12 sunny
sides the one um that was received on
the 27th of july so
that is um
to the
west so
yeah so you've got 675 there now that
goes up so you've got 12 then you've got
13 and then you've got 14.
okay so to go on with the presentation
this is the location plan and so i've
pointed out it is a terrace um within
easter water
so it's a built-up residential area
we'll get one to the next
slide so this is just showing kind of
existing elevations and plans of
the sites at present you've got the
block plan there the bottom right corner
and then we've got the rear elevation
and the two side elevations at present
so this is just the existing floor plan
just to kind of establish what's what's
already on site the downstairs you kind
of got the kitchen living dining with
the bathroom and then upstairs is a
larger bedroom
so this is just some photos this is from
the site looking east
so that is 14 sunny sides that you're
kind of looking at and then as you go up
15 16.
so this is directly looking north so in
that photo there you've got the um
atkins dwelling and then to the side
there you've got 14 selling sides um
with
their kind of two-story extension and
windows that they have there
so this is just looking north again to
show kind of the development that's on
the site
and then this is looking west so that is
part of um 12 sunny side
who put the
late objection comment in
so this is just looking south west from
from the african
property and then looking south
then this is looking east again just
into those neighbors windows so um just
for clarification um the one kind of on
the side of the two two-story extension
there is a bathroom
and one kind of facing when you kind of
look more north that is currently used
as kind of a bedroom slash study
so this is looking south from the first
floor window of the application site
and so just to gauge in terms of the
proposal where the black um kind of
fluid there that is how far it's going
out so there will be still some of the
flat roof and originally the extension
on the first application did cover most
of that flat roof so it has been brought
back for this resubmission
since just looking southeast from the
first floor window of the application
site
and so then this is looking west from
the first floor of the neighbouring
dwellings so i did go and visit the
neighbours and dwelling to
see the application from their point of
view once again
yeah that's the view from number 14. so
that's the view
yesterday
so no so the letter was from number
twelve
number four on oh
that came in yesterday there was one
from number 12 and number 14. so yes
this is from number 14 that will be read
out as
part of the public participation
so this is just looking again from that
kind of this is looking from the bedroom
kind of study room
of what what can be um seen at the
moment as you can see from that the the
kind of flu that is the kind of point of
reference is is out of sight currently
so this is from downstairs just looking
at the view from one of the bottom
windows already from the neighbours
dwelling
and that's just it again kind of with
the curtains back kind of looking
further into their garden
and that's just kind of a more straight
down view that is into the neighbors
dwelling
and the boundary there is part of the
applicant's dwelling already
this is just looking from the ground
floor at the kitchen
[Music]
and then this is looking from the
neighbour's garden
as you can see
you can see the applicants dwelling and
then obviously the neighbors dwelling
with that that window again that that
has been in concern
and that's just looking more northwest
from the neighbour's garden
and just around again to have that
reference point of the food there
so these are the proposed plans um as
stated this is a resubmission and it has
been brought back and
redesigned to
emit some of the concerns that we we had
previously
so it will now um include a bedroom at
the first floor
and then an internal alteration to
create a new um staircase and a bathroom
at first floor and then downstairs once
again is being reconfigured but that's
outside the the planning
so that that just shows the first floor
as you can see there what they've done
on that first floor is angled it away so
um the original submission kind of went
the full width of the dwelling and
further out to the flat roof and that
has been minimized to kind of overcome
any concerns in terms of
immunity a condition has been put on
that no windows can be put in the east
or west elevation without further
consultation with the local authority
another concern was that the black group
could be used at the balcony so there's
another condition that's been put on
today that that can't be used at the
balcony unless further commissions
obtained from the local authority
so in terms of planning considerations
one principle of development is within
the development boundary of eastern
water so our first kind of um point is
the mo
dm 25 and sto6 that kind of promotes um
extensions for the householder
in terms of impact on character and
appearance it thinks that there are two
story elements along this terrace
already and the active has scaled the
the extension back in itself felt by
your case officer that it is of an
appropriate scale and character for the
terrorist area
impact on residential ability this has
been assessed like i said there's no
windows on the east and west elevation
and the condition has been put on to
make sure that these can't be put in
with committed development rights and if
in the future windows did want to be put
in they have to be put in as a full
application to the local authority
in terms of ecology that has been
satisfied so in conclusion the case
officer is recommending approval for the
application
thank you sure
[Music]
i'm sending my position
above planning application in this
written submission by email as requested
by office because i am unable to attend
the meeting at 9 30
in person
to the committee
i have received no previous consultation
from the application submission at 13
studying by with any warning or reasons
for the above application which i oppose
on the very strongest term because i
feel any type of large development
project the one described first floor
extension would be totally unsuitable
for these kind of dwelling for the
following reasons listed below okay
some of these 150 year old dwellings
have had ground floor extensions added
on over the years which have proved
sustainable in most countries that an
ambitious versatile building added on
could cause risks to the existing
foundation
the ground these dwellings were situated
on have proved well established after
the present day but looking at today's
projected change in climate conditions
in future years such as months of heavy
rain or drought could make the ground
area unstable especially as the row of
houses and surrounding buildings are
placed in step formation on a steep hill
leading down the river flooring
as far as i know these houses have never
had any serious issues in the past in
their present form that heavy
development of the above
first floor extension at number 13 could
make the ground become unstable putting
the surrounding houses seriously from
conditions described above possibly
causing
the building foundation
a large building project as described in
the proposal would cause an extreme
amount of disruption of the lives of the
occupants of sunny side and surrounding
property which would include the
following
parking parking is very limited in this
area and visited plant vehicles could
increase the danger of safe parking
space and could block emergency and
service vehicles from safe passage
through the street
dust and noise pollution
a building project of this size and
proposed could cause an unbearable
amount of dust and debris in the air
around the site area many residents
would be affected by the resulting dirty
air and the mess to their homes cars and
general health and well-being recording
damage to property and stress to many
residents and noise levels on a project
of this size would be unacceptable to
myself and other residents in the
vicinity of the site of this quiet area
see with the first for extension i've
described from the application in the
past it would set a precedent which made
home which many homeowners and sunnyside
would bitterly regret today's climate
build anything anywhere develop a
culture which i'd hoped to escape from
my previous location in west london
sunnyside is one of if not the prettiest
streets and benefit and it would be a
great shame to bury it i'm doing a
tournament culture
extension
i am firmly against this development
thank you and our second letter that the
heathen will read out is from trudy
mackey brown
against
the um occupy 14 20
i wish for my letters to be read out of
the prepared planning committee meeting
the above property i am unable to attend
due to work i am raising an objection to
the proposal for the following reasons
loss of natural light the proposed
extension will affect my property and
have an immense impact through loss of
natural light into my property the
kitchen sitting room bedroom and
bathroom
the distance between mine and number 13
is only 1.2 meters water wall therefore
the extension will affect me directly
and make my property considerably darker
especially through the winter months
because of natural light
this will impact upon me financially and
is of a great concern the cost of energy
prices rising significantly and it's
unfair i will have to bear the brunt of
people
loss of privacy the length of the
proposed extension with juliet vermin
and french style doors will overlook
directly in my garden and i will lose
the privacy i currently have
my neighbour at number 13 is particular
to any impact on their privacy so they
should respect mine as well
environmental impact using more
electricity when we are encouraged by
government to reduce our carbon
footprint
i also feel very concerned the extension
can set a precedent for more development
and extensions to other properties in
the street which will affect everyone
the cottages are 150 years old and
it is unknown as to what the impact
further development could have upon them
have the extension should it go ahead
will have an impact on my health and
well-being physically and mentally i
have two chronic health conditions one
of which is the disability both the
great exasperated by strength and
anxiety i'm concerned the impact of the
extension and the potential for
increased financial pressure upon myself
from extra energy costs and dark and
living environment will increase my
health risks
sarah boyle planning office has visited
my property and taking photos which i
understand are available for you to see
thank you
now we have a letter in support
from the applicant concerning clause
thank you for taking the time to listen
to my statement i will start by
explaining the reasons as to why i have
submitted a planning application for a
small extension i have not done this in
a monetary game for any other reason
other than to give my mum who is 89
years of age at home so i can look after
and care for her in 80 years for the
health and safety of mum it was agreed
by the family that she could come to
live with me and that i would apply for
planning to allow them to have our own
bedroom and shower room upstairs
my bathroom being on the ground floor
and i'm concerned with mum having to go
downstairs during the night
i would drew the previous application
after receiving
comment disparaging comments in my
previous neighborhood number 14 and to
review the proposal to see if i could
overcome the concerns raised by both my
neighbour and the then potential
purchaser of number 14. i arranged a
meeting with the purchaser and estate
agent prior to extinct exchange of
contracts to discuss the proposal and
resubmission of the application the
purchaser cancelled that meeting and
moved into the property in january 2022
after consultation for the planning
officer
and numerous amendments being made for
drawing i resubmitted the application on
a much smaller scale reducing the
additional bedroom from a double to a
small single i refer to the comments
made in the options objection statements
as follows objection statement from
number 14 done inside regarding the
ground floor extension at my property
firstly these works were carried out
prior to my purchasing and moving in
2004 and secondly as far as i'm aware
from investigations made the bay under
the boundaries joined
lots of natural daylight the design of
the extension has been drastically
changed to ensure that the planning
guidance regarding the 45 percent
sideline have been enhanced this has
been accepted by the planning officer
overlooking and privacy
living in a terrorist property
there will always be an element of
overlooking from neighboring first floor
windows
objection statement from number fifteen
somebody said
the owner of number 15 cannot see my
property nor will he see the extension
because of the firstborn extension
number 14.
um the comment of if wanting to expand
should move to a more suitable property
property is not an option and i feel as
a personal choice and of no concerns
i do not wish to move as i love my
cottage and i've lived there for over 18
years
in relation to parking on numerous
occasions there are vehicles in the
streets belonging to persons working in
sunny times this has never been an issue
but many of the residents work and would
not be parked there during the day
anyway
there are larger vehicles on occasions
in sunnyside but as far as i'm aware
this has never been an issue they're
there for a short period of time just to
unload and move on
a neighbor across the road who owns the
garage that runs onto the street have
told me he has no problem with delivery
vehicles parking there to unload
materials so this is not an issue
drainage sewage and structural issues i
failed to see if the negative attacks
the development would have on these
issues obviously these methods will be
correctly leveled when the work is being
undertaken
i feel like i've done all i can to
address the concerns objections raised
and i truly believe that small extension
would not have a detrimental impact on
those to give mom and myself a better
quality of life the addition of a small
bedroom and an upstairs showroom is
essential for her long-term care
and my sanity i appreciate the
consideration given to this application
and hope you feel you thinking to
support the proposal
i have recently received an email from
mrs cawdy regarding her planning
application i have seen the plans and
the objections i would like it noted
that i fully support this extension
given the fact that mrs cawley has
recently had to look after her elderly
mother who has health issues and a
degenerative eye condition the extension
isn't about financial gain it is to give
her mother her own bedroom with a shower
room i see no reason why this planning
application cannot be passed through
given the fact that one of the neighbors
objective has only just moved in
also from objections are mentioning
their views across the river and there's
no reason to project i hope you can
accept the planning and grant permission
thank you
that's the end of the contributions
question first so can i have i got it
right that number 14
okay
already has a first floor extension to
the rear yes that's correct i find it
bigger than leaking
yeah
[Music]
i mean all right for me but not for you
all right thank you
used to live just a couple of doors up
again i've been in a house i've been to
the bottom of god there are other
extensions on the first floor it isn't
the only one for
um
parking of course is totally irrelevant
in this issue it's not a planning issue
here
and i was slightly amused by the idea of
darkness
because it's called sunny side for a
perfect for a reason and it faces south
in front of these guys face up at the
back
they're all west facing uh they all get
the same amount of sunlight and i i
don't quite understand what they're
talking about because all the sun is on
the south
of these ones so i don't think that
applies either um and i will propose the
acceptors yeah
our second gen thank you councilwoman
yeah
um
i mean i
a lot's been done i printed off a couple
of them the floor plans
and when you look at the uh
the exposed extension on top
as a flat roof it only goes out
for joining number 14. i just over a
meter and then that angle piece
comes in which cuts nearly a third of
what would have been the room off
and the window in number 14 upstairs
uh
stephen story is a bathroom window
obscured again that's the place that
they don't look out for them the kitchen
window down below
looks across
the side of all the extensions itself
i think angling the book i mean i think
they've been very generously african in
england that would almost be on the call
of duty
um
but it's been recorded unless anybody
else wants to make comments
i i really haven't got any problem of
course
it came to us because it is a member of
stanford
so it's been proposed by council
christie certainly by councillor watson
to approve this came to the vote please
john chancellor brown
councillor christie four councillor
craigie
councillor harding ford chancellor
leather four customers
[Music]
thank
141 278
[Music]
[Music]
that was the main reason for it
okay
we'll move on then to
foster mobile's world
costs one of these item 10 on the agenda
is admv applications major 160 970
item 11
planning decisions
the list of delegated planning decisions
consultancy abbreviations and
application tags
from 26th of may to the 14th of july
pages 171
to 189
[Music]
[Music]
permission
[Music]
so class q has been committed
development right within the general
community development order for change
of use from agricultural buildings to
dwellings
and
so let me just see exactly what that
related to
yeah so so there is a principle that's
been established through
through planning law but if if a class
queue as we call it if there is a
consent in place through committed
development for a change of use
then um there is a fallback position
that an applicant can come forward to
demolish that building and build a new
dwelling that the the test that we apply
based on the case law is that there must
be a betterment so
um
for us
mistakes the nightmare
absolutely well yes i mean
lots of class queues there was really
clever valley
yeah
right okay
[Music]